Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim.
Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 110.
Ausgabe von UKW 1.1.0,
euer Notruf in Zeiten der Krise und darum geht es natürlich heute wieder.
Nach drei Monaten mittlerweile wollen wir ein Update machen über die Ukraine
und dazu begrüße ich selbstverständlich Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, denn wir haben schon die ganze Zeit mit argus Augen immer wieder so auf
den Podcast Knopf geschaut und uns überlegt, wann wäre es wohl der richtige
Zeitpunkt mal wieder eine Wasserstandsmeldung abzugeben.
Kann sich ja auch schnell so dieser Eindruck herausstellen, wir würden uns nicht
mehr mit dem Thema beschäftigen,
das haben wir sicherlich nicht mehr mit derselben Intensität getan,
wie noch vor einigen Monaten, aber ich zumindest bin schon so,
in so einem Daily News Update bin ich schon drin. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir so geht?
Jaja, auf jeden Fall, so spätestens, also ich glaube, maximal habe ich mal drei
Tage weggesehen oder so, länger nicht.
So ähnlich geht's mir auch, wobei ich jetzt nicht mehr wie am Anfang den ganzen
Tag über die vollständige Timeline einsauge.
Leider ist ja jetzt auch durch den Niedergang von Twitter so eine ganz wichtige
Nachrichtenquelle etwas volatil geworden, es ist einfach nicht mehr so einfach mit dieser scheiß,
Software die sie da jetzt rausgehauen haben.
Würde nicht sagen dass er zum versiegen gekommen ist aber man merkt schon dass
andere themen deutlich mehr raum einnehmen.
Ja, definitiv. Wobei auf Twitter sich halt jetzt auch viele unzensierte Videos befinden,
die sonst, wo man dann eher auf Telegram oder so suchen musste.
Ja ist eh interessant, wie sich jetzt sozusagen diese ganze Nachrichtenquellenlage verändert.
Also auf Twitter ist nach wie vor viel Wildes von vielen Accounts,
wo man aber auch immer sehr vorsichtig sein muss, was einem da alles so vorgeworfen
wird, weil da ist halt viel Fake dabei von beiden Seiten.
YouTube hat wiederum harte Regeln, die sie auch durchsetzen,
wo die Leute dann halt entweder demonetarisiert werden, wie das so schön heißt
oder ihre Videos komplett gesperrt werden, wenn sie allzu garstiges Zeug zeigen.
Was in meiner wahrnehmung extrem zugenommen hat
sind so längere artikel blockartig auf substack
das scheint jetzt wirklich ein ding zu sein
da werden dann wiederum auch die ganzen original videos
geliefert und dann natürlich klar so wie du schon sagst auf telegram gibt es
natürlich extrem viel kanäle die nicht jetzt persönlich ehrlich gesagt nicht
ganz so viel folge aber ab und zu ist da ja auch mal so primärquelle zu finden
etc aber das ist dann schon für die absoluten news junkies die gar nichts mehr anderes hören wollen.
Ja.
So würde ich das mal charakterisieren gerade die mediale situation und meine
und dann noch halt deine situation.
Ja, aber in den letzten Tagen habe ich dann noch mal eine ganze Menge auch durchgearbeitet
und bin noch auf viele Dinge gestoßen,
die mir dann so tatsächlich entgangen waren in den letzten drei Monaten und
einige davon sind doch jetzt schon sehr relevant,
um die Situation einzuschätzen und auch wie es weitergeht und ob die Gegenoffensive
schon begonnen hat oder wann sie beginnen wird.
All das sind Fragen, mit denen wir uns auch noch beschäftigen werden heute.
Genau. Wir fangen an mit einem Rückblick und wir wollen halt mal so ein bisschen,
also das Ding ist, also wann immer wir uns darüber unterhalten haben mit irgendwie
machen wir jetzt eine Sendung, war eigentlich mal unsere beiderseitige Aussage
immer so, passiert ja nix.
Das ist natürlich absurd zu behaupten, dass da nichts passieren würde.
Natürlich passiert da am laufenden Meter den ganzen Tag around the clock etwas.
Vor allem wird viel gekämpft, geschossen und gestorben und das ist alles nach
wie vor total dramatisch.
Die Aussage passiert ja nix, war halt im Puncto an der militärischen Gesamtlage
hat sich nicht viel geändert.
Und das obwohl eigentlich der Winter und da zählen dann im Prinzip die letzten
drei Monate auch noch mit dazu,
Die Russen sich sehr wohl bemüht haben eine Offensive,
eine Winteroffensive durchzuführen, sie haben am Eingang,
am Anfang dieses Winters auch viel darüber spekuliert worden,
wer würde denn jetzt sozusagen einen Vorteil davon haben von diesen Wintersituationen,
dann war teilweise der Winter erstmal nicht da, aber generell kann man sagen,
Die aktive Rolle hat Russland eingenommen, indem sie einfach alles,
was sie an Menschenmaterial aufgreifen können, an die Front geworfen haben.
Und sie haben sich vor allem an drei Orten festgebissen.
Also während so im Bereich Kherson und Zaporizhia,
also quasi im Südwesten und im Süden des Konfliktgebietes der Frontlinie im
Wesentlichen so eigentlich alles gleich geblieben ist und keine größeren Auseinandersetzungen waren.
Klar, irgendwelche Special Ops und irgendwelche Scharmützel und hier und da
mal ein kleiner Testangriff,
aber da waren einfach von beiden Seiten keine nennenswerten Truppenkonzentrationen
beziehungsweise keine Bereitschaft da groß in irgendeiner Form in die Offensive
zu gehen und ähnlich verhält es sich halt auch so im Nordbereich.
Und also in der Rakiv-Luhansk-Frontlinie gibt es zwar auch immer wieder kleinere
Auseinandersetzungen,
aber so von Norden bis nach Kremina war eigentlich im Großen und Ganzen hat sich nicht viel getan.
Anders sah es dann halt aus bei wesentlichen drei Orten im Donbass.
Da ist vor allem die Stadt Bachmuth zu nennen und dann etwas weiter südlich
die Stadt Avdivka und dann noch mal etwas südlich dann so langsam in diesen,
nach Westen in diesen Knick der Frontlinie hinein die Stadt Wuledar.
Das waren so drei Orte, wo die Russen einfach massiv vorgestoßen sind,
mit unterschiedlichem Erfolg.
Wurde da, um es gleich mal vorwegzunehmen, haben sie sich,
ein paar richtige Korken geleistet, dort sind sie also mit Panzern losmarschiert
und offensichtlich sind die aber auch von Leuten angeführt worden,
die einfach von der ganzen Kampftechnik nichts verstehen,
weder von der Strategie noch von den Geräten und sind also vernichtend geschlagen worden,
da gab es also verschiedenste Scharmützel bei denen einfach diese ganzen Angriffe
komplett niedergeschlagen wurden und die Russen an einem Tag 20,
30 Panzer oder zumindest schweres Gerät verloren haben etc.
Also bei Wuleda sind sie überhaupt keinen Schritt vorangekommen und auch in Avdivka,
was auch so eine Stadt ist, die halt direkt vor der großen Stadt Donetsk liegt,
die aber einfach uneinnehmbar ist für die Russen.
Also auch da gab es zwar hier und da ein paar Geländegewinne,
aber wir reden hier von hunderten von Metern und nichts signifikantem.
Und im Großen und Ganzen ist also an diesen beiden Orten die Situation wirklich komplett unverändert.
Ein bisschen anders ist es halt in Bachmuth, wo die Russen massiv Leute reingeschmissen
haben und man muss sich das so vorstellen,
dass sie den ganzen Tag über in 10er, 20er Gruppen die Frontlinie angegriffen
haben und zwar nicht eine Gruppe pro Tag, sondern 10,
15 solcher Gruppen pro Tag und das an vielen Stellen dieser Front.
Und diese Abnutzung, die hat einerseits dazu geführt, dass die Russen halt langsam
Fortschritte erzielen und jetzt, wo wir diese Sendung aufnehmen,
sieht es so aus, als ob jetzt Bachmutter eigentlich Ende dieser Woche gefallen sein wird.
Nur die Verluste, die die Russen dort eingefahren haben, die sind...
Nach dem, was man beurteilen kann, enorm, ja,
also wirklich sehr sehr sehr hohe Verluste und das scheint ein wenig die Motivation
der Ukrainer gewesen zu sein,
entgegen dem Rat vieler von außen,
die gesagt haben, hier zieht euch doch zurück, das ist irgendwie alles total
blutig, da verliert ihr viele Leute, aber die Grundhaltung von der Ukraine war
halt so, nö, Wir rücken hier überhaupt nicht ab und das ist einfach die Gelegenheit
hier den Russen großen Schaden zuzuführen.
Das ist dann auch später für unsere Offensive hilfreich.
Das ist nochmal so der grobe Rahmen in dem sich diese letzten drei Monate abgespielt haben.
Und es hat halt auch die Ukrainer so ein bisschen mehr von der Verpflichtung enthoben,
jetzt selber in die Offensive gehen zu müssen.
Sondern konnten einfach da sitzen und die Russen kommen lassen lassen und einfach
ihren Vorteil ausspielen,
als Verteidiger so mit einfach weniger Verluste zu haben,
als wenn sie selbst hätten in die Offensive gehen müssen,
weil was sie natürlich nicht wollten war, dass die Russen jetzt in Ruhe dort
sich einrichten und ihre Truppen aufbauen und stärker werden,
sondern die wollten die ja abnutzen und dann besser, wenn man sie angreifen
lässt, als wenn man selber angreift.
Also das ist so ein bisschen das Big Picture der letzten drei Monate.
Wir wollen jetzt mal so ein bisschen die Timeline der drei Monate mal so ein
bisschen durchgehen und ein paar Sachen herausgreifen,
die jetzt jenseits dieses permanenten Fronttätigkeit passiert sind,
die vielleicht Hinweise darauf geben lassen, wie es um die Ukrainer,
Russland, innen wie außen bestellt ist, was sich technisch tut und so weiter.
Wieso dieses Gesamtgefüge Krieg voranschreit, weil natürlich ist ja auch klar,
die reinkriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen,
das ist das eine, aber auch die ganze politische Klammer, die sich um diesen
Konflikt herum gebildet hat, spielt natürlich eine große Rolle dabei,
wann und wie die Ukraine zuschlagen kann.
Aber gehen wir doch mal in den März rein, was dort passiert ist,
seitdem wir berichtet haben das letzte Mal. A.
Ja, naja erstmal kurz nach der letzten Sendung gab es ja noch viel Aufregung
um Moldova und Transnistrien.
Russland behauptete, die Ukraine wolle in Transnistrien einmarschieren und deswegen
dort Truppen verstärken und hat dann auch ja politisch Unruhen gemacht mit Hilfe
des Bevölkerungsteils, der da mit ihnen sympathisierte.
Aber ja, es hat sich dann zum Glück wieder beruhigt.
Vielleicht sollte man noch kurz erwähnen, für die Leute, die mit dem Begriff
nichts anfangen können.
Also Transnistrien, das ist so dieser östliche Streifen,
kann man fast sagen, von der Republik Moldau, der sich eben so unabhängig erklärt
hat und der halt unter russischem Einfluss ist. Das ist so eine dieser merkwürdigen
russischen Satellitengebiete.
Die haben da seinerzeit dann in den Anfang der 90er Unruhen inszeniert und dann
Friedenstruppen geschickt,
die da noch immer stationiert sind, so 1600 russische Friedenstruppen und haben
dort auch eines der größten Munitionsdepots in Europa.
Das ist so nur ein paar hundert Meter, maximal, ich glaube, ich habe das mal
in der Karte geguckt, ein paar Kilometer von der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt.
Also wenn die Ukrainer wollten, so wären die da ruckzuck drin.
Ist aber im Prinzip so eine Region wie Abrasien und Süd-Ossetien in Georgien,
also wo Russland einfach seinen Einfluss geltend gemacht hat,
indem sie sich einfach mal ein bisschen militär reinbewegt haben,
so dass sich dann keiner getraut hat, da etwas dagegen zu tun.
Der letzte militärische Konflikt
Georgien und Russland ist ja nicht so gut ausgegangen für Georgien.
Und ja, in Moldau drohte im Prinzip immer dasselbe. Und auch dieser ganze Vorstoß nach Odessa,
der roch natürlich von vornherein danach, dass Russland auch gerne diese Brücke
schließen, also diese Verbindung schließen möchte, ist ihnen Gott sei Dank nicht gelungen.
Was noch passiert? BK'IN DR.
GERICHT Ja, dann so in der Kategorie so Beschuss der Krim.
Das ging so im März dann los mit einem ziemlich erfolgreichen Angriff in der Nähe von Dzangkoy,
wo wohl ein Zug mit Kaliber KN-Cruise Missiles beladen,
explodiert ist und die waren auf den Weg zu U-Booten und sollten dann auf die
Ukraine geschossen worden.
Das war wohl ja ein bemerkenswerter Erfolg. Das war teuer für die Russen.
Tancoy muss man dazu sagen, ist so ein Verkehrsknotenpunkt im Norden der Krim.
Ganz wichtige Stadt in der Hinsicht, wo sich die, wo sich zwei große Straßen
treffen, die, von denen es nicht so viele gibt in der Krim.
Ja, und das ist John Coyle.
Ja, dann kam ja Mitte März dann noch der Haftbefehl gegen Putin vom International
Criminal Court in Den Haag,
worauf natürlich die Russen mit Angriffen auf Den Haag drohten und die Extremisten
dann verlangten, Den Haag jetzt zu nuken, falls irgendwie.
Ja, es gab dann jedenfalls viel Aufregung drum.
Und grundsätzlich aber eine gute Sache.
Und sie haben interessanterweise als unbestreitbare Grundlage dafür die Verschleppung
von Kindern aus der Ukraine genommen,
die halt gut dokumentiert ist Und wo man nicht lange diskutieren muss, was da passiert ist.
Es ist definitiv ein Verstoß gegen das Völkerrecht und gilt halt als Genozid
im Prinzip. Und da war die Sache dann relativ klar.
Putin war nicht begeistert.
Muss er damit leben? Ja, das ist natürlich von der Ukraine schwer gefeiert worden,
auch wenn es natürlich eben klar ist, dass es jetzt erstmal keine unmittelbaren
Konsequenzen hat, aber im Prinzip schränkt es natürlich seine Reisefreiheit ein.
Das ist jetzt natürlich alle Länder, die im Prinzip dort sich verpflichtet haben
solchen Haftbefehlen Folge zu leisten, verpflichtet werden halt Putin zu überstellen.
Ja gut, in der Praxis wird das eigentlich so aussehen, dass wenn er dann wirklich
irgendwo hin muss oder will, dass die den schon auch aussetzen können oder ihm
freies Geleit bieten können.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass er jetzt nicht, ja also wenn man will.
Ich denke es gibt Länder, die er jetzt erst mal nicht auf der Liste hat.
Ja.
Also es macht auf jeden Fall für die Gastgeber irgendwie macht es das schwieriger
gerade so im Bereich der neutralen Länder.
Da wird er dann im Zweifelsfall eher nochmal ausgeladen nach dem Motto wollen
wir uns nicht anziehen in den Schuhen.
Gehen wir in den April, da sind eine interessante neue Bewegung ein, wie ich finde,
nämlich Angriffe, Attentate auf russische Militärblogger, Nationalisten,
So Figuren, die besonders dafür bekannt waren,
in diesem Krieg sozusagen so voll auf der russischen Seite zu sein und auch
selber so ein bisschen Teil einer eigenen Propagandawelle zu sein.
Also russische Rechtsextremisten.
Der erste war Tatarski. Wer ist denn das?
Ja, das war eine sehr, sehr seltsame Kiste.
Das war ja dann in einem Lokal von Prigogine, wo meine Frau eine Statue überreicht
hat, in der dann eine Bombe war.
Und was dann daraufhin passierte, auch irgendwie in den Medien, war auch sehr seltsam.
Also Frau blieb dann auch am Tatort, war selber irgendwie wohl verwirrt von
dem was passiert ist und ja und dann gab es auch noch ein seltsames Interview
mit ihr, alles sehr mysteriös.
Es ist sehr schwer einzuschätzen, was da jetzt genau passiert ist einerseits
und was jetzt auch sich mit den
ganzen anderen Fällen, die wir auch noch erwähnen werden, mit verbindet.
Es ist überhaupt auch nicht klar, wer jetzt eigentlich hinter diesen Anschlägen steckt.
Also es gibt alle möglichen Motivationen für alle möglichen Gründe,
die kann man dann als mehr oder weniger wahrscheinlich erachten,
aber es ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so ganz klar,
ob das jetzt sozusagen Rachefeldzüge seitens der Ukraine sind,
was ich selber für eher unwahrscheinlich halte,
Oder ob es irgendwelche vom russischen Staat organisierten Dinge sind,
um hier in irgendeiner Form selbsternannte Propaganda Outlets auszuschalten,
die aber auf der anderen Seite so dermaßen eigentlich auf Staatslinie liegen,
dass man sich darüber auch nur wundern könnte.
Oder ob es nicht irgendwelche Querschießer sind in einem der Geheimdienste,
die mit was weiß ich für welchen Machtstrukturen in irgendeiner Form nicht zufrieden
sind und darüber versuchen Unruhe zu stiften. Also sehr schwer einzuschätzen.
Ja, und dann sind diese Leute aber oft ja auch noch in alle möglichen kriminellen
Geschäfte verwickelt. Da geht es dann auch noch um Geld und organisiertes Verbrechen.
Ja, das ist nicht so knapp.
Also insofern schwierig zu beurteilen. Ja, ja, dann...
Gab es als nächstes halt dieses Leak von amerikanischen Geheimdienstdokumenten,
die dann auch noch zur Aufdeckung von Donbass-Devushka führten.
Eine amerikanische Ex-Offizierin, Sarah Bills eigentlich, die sich ja ein Geschäft daraus gemacht hat,
sich eine falsche Identität als Russin aus dem Donbass aufgebaut hat,
mit einem gefakten russischen Akzent gesprochen hat und sich Hunderttausende
von Followern aufgebaut hat und das wohl als sie noch im aktiven Dienst bei der Navy war.
Also, wilde Sache.
Diese Leaks waren ja selber für sich ja jetzt auch erstmal interessant.
Das hat ja mit dieser Frau erstmal so nichts zu tun.
Naja, sie war diejenige, die das quasi bekannt gemacht hat,
indem sie allerdings eine mit Photoshop manipulierte Version eines der Dokumente
gepostet hat und tatsächlich sind die ja geleakt worden.
Wiederum von einem Soldaten der National Guard,
Teixeira ist der glaube ich,
der sich damit aber einfach nur vor Freunden profilieren wollte,
auf einem Discord-Server angeben wollte,
mit dem was er alles weiß und quasi in so einer Internet-Debatte einfach bestehen
wollte, der mir dann gesagt hat, du hast ja keine Ahnung, hier,
guck dir mal an, was ich da wirklich weiß.
Also eigentlich ein Angeber, der sich damit vor seinen Spielerfreunden profilieren.
Wollte.
Und gut, mit Ausnahme auch von dem Kursieren der Fälschung scheinen die wohl
im Wesentlichen authentisch zu sein, aber da jetzt auch nicht ewig drauf aufzuhalten.
Also wirklich Sensationelles oder Überraschendes war da jetzt nicht drin.
Und auch Geheimdienste wissen ja nicht immer so gut Bescheid.
Man erinnere sich nur an den Anfang des Krieges, wo
sowohl amerikanische wie auch russische geheimdienste
alle komplett daneben gelegen haben wie sich
das wohl entwickeln würde und ansonsten ja
in den unterlagen gehen wohl der amerikanische geheimdienst von doppelt so hohen
verlusten auf russischer seite aus wie auf auf ukrainischer seite und das war
er hatten wir aber schon in den ersten Wochen bei den Oryx-Zahlen,
bei den Materialverlusten und es ist aber auch unklar jetzt,
ob in den Zahlen für die
russische Seite auch jetzt Wagner und DNR und LNR-Truppen eingeschlossen sind
und die Zahlen stammen auch aus der Zeit ein bisschen noch vor der russischen
Offensive da waren halt auch nicht mehr unbedingt auf dem neuesten Stand.
Und dann gab es halt noch die Diskussion, dass die Ukraine knapp an Luftabwehrraketen zu sein scheint,
aber das hatten wir ja auch hier schon debattiert, so und ist jetzt auch keine
Überraschung, aber wie wir später noch sehen werden, sind Ihnen die jetzt noch nicht ausgegangen.
Ja auch den Russen nicht, also sowohl.
Alles mögliche ist darüber spekuliert worden, bisher gibt es immer noch irgendwie Nachschub.
Also diese Leaks das war natürlich ein großer Aufreger und natürlich hat sich
die USA auch sofort bemüht dem jungen Mann das Leben möglichst schwer zu machen,
nebst Kamera, Fernsehkompatibler Festnahme.
Da wird sie jetzt sicherlich nicht so eine gute Zeit haben, das war aber halt
auch wirklich eine scheiß Idee so,
das kann man ja auch nicht anders sagen, das hätte er ja nicht besser wissen
müssen, aber so ist das halt nur mal mit so Dummheiten, denke nicht,
dass ihm da jetzt besonders viel Jugendlichkeit zugestanden werden wird,
das ist natürlich dramatisch, aber kann man jetzt auch nicht ändern.
Tatsache ist, okay das waren zwar jetzt Dokumente, aber das ganze Kriegsgeschehen
ist natürlich auch extrem schnelllebig.
Wir wissen jetzt natürlich nicht inwiefern jetzt irgendwelche wahren Fernaussagen
oder Termine oder so weiter gelten,
aber ich glaube auch ganz ehrlich, die Amerikaner mögen Erkenntnisse haben,
die mögen auch Dinge mitgeteilt bekommen, aber ich denke auch nicht,
dass sie alles wissen, was die Ukrainer so vor sich haben, weil es gibt bei
aller Verbundenheit auch so ein natürliches Misstrauen auf beiden Seiten.
Und damit sind sie beide bisher gut gefahren. BK'IN WIRKLICHEN.
Ja und zumal die Markings auf den Dokumenten waren auch von der Geheimhaltungsstufe,
dass die halt auch mit der gesamten Nato geteilt werden und mit den Five Eyes so und ja,
da schreibt man halt eigentlich kritische Sachen nicht rein, weil klar ist,
dass was weiß ich, ja jetzt da sitzen dann halt auch Ungarn mit drin,
die dann Zeugs leaken und so und das heißt,
Da steht auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so viel kritisches Zeug drin und tatsächlich
gab es dann auch Kommentare,
dass die Amerikaner besser über die Russen Bescheid wissen, was was die machen,
als was die Ukrainer tun.
Gut, moving on.
Ja, so ein anderer Meilenstein, so im April, war auch, dass die Ukraine ihre
Stromexporte wieder aufgenommen hat.
Also, war jetzt dann doch nicht so erfolgreich, die ganze Kampagne,
die Ukraine da das Stromnetz zu zerstören.
Und es gab wohl seit Februar auch schon wieder Reservekapazitäten,
wurde anlässlich dessen bekannt gegeben.
Aber man hat das erstmal noch im Land gelassen und jetzt exportiert die Ukraine wieder Strom.
Das ist bemerkenswert eigentlich. Also erstmal finde ich es bemerkenswert,
dass sie überhaupt so viel Strom produzieren, den sie dann nicht selber benötigen
und dass sie das halt auch noch unter diesen Bedingungen tun können.
Und das obwohl ihr größtes Kernkraftwerk derzeit überhaupt nicht dabei ist.
Ja, dann ging es weiter so, dass dann so nach und nach wieder jetzt zugesagte
Lieferungen Eintrafen,
zum Beispiel die Slowakei, hat dann tatsächlich die Lieferung von 13 Jets abgeschlossen im April.
Und ja, ansonsten, ja natürlich sind jeden Tag Dinge passiert,
aber vielleicht noch zu erwähnen, dass dann auch noch mal Jens Stoltenberg so
verkündet hat für die NATO,
dass jetzt wohl die Ukraine Soldaten für neun gepanzerte Brigaden trainiert hat.
Und das wären je nachdem zwischen 15.000 und 40.000 Mann und mehrere hundert
Panzer und hunderte Weiterfahrzeuge.
Und der Westen soll zu dem Zeitpunkt auch oder seit Kriegsbeginn 230 Panzer
und 1550 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge geliefert haben.
Was sagen wir, die Wasserstandsmeldung Ende,
April.
Also überhaupt ist sozusagen, also was daran bemerkenswert ist,
dass das offensichtlich nach den Panzerbeschlüssen,
die wir glaube ich in der letzten Sendung noch drin hatten, wo Deutschland sich
dann durchgerungen hat Leoparden zu liefern,
Leopard 2, aber Leopard 1 dann auch und also ich hatte das Gefühl mit dieser
Panzerdiskussion ist so ein Damm gebrochen in der Bereitschaft.
Des Westens hier zu liefern.
Da kommen wir auch nochmal bei den Langstreckenwaffen auch nochmal drauf,
sowas ähnliches spielt sich jetzt glaube ich gerade wieder ab und es gibt auch noch eine dritte Runde,
wenn es dann um Flugzeuge geht, die glaube ich dann auch noch innerhalb der
nächsten Monate auch nochmal Einzug halten wird.
Aber das ist halt jetzt noch hier dieses ganze Komplex Ausbildung und Panzerlieferung
und Ausbildung an diesen Panzern. Also das Trainieren komplett neuer Brigaden.
Also wir reden jetzt hier ja quasi von einer neuen Armee von Leuten,
die noch überhaupt gar keine Kampferfahrung haben oder wenig Kampferfahrung haben.
Und die rekrutiert worden sind, die jetzt in den letzten Monaten in der Ukraine
oder eben dann bei Führungskräften und Leuten, die halt Technik anbieten.
Komplexe westliche Technik bedienen sollen, die sind dann halt in Deutschland,
in England, Dänemark, überall wahrscheinlich in allen NATO Ländern,
werden in irgendeiner Form ukrainische Soldaten ausgebildet und das ist so ein
bisschen die Zusammenfassung hier von Stoltenberg,
ob die Zahlen dann halt so passen wissen wir nicht, aber das ist das was passiert
ist, also es ist einfach im Wesentlichen die Zeit genutzt worden,
eine neue Armee aufzuziehen, die im Idealfall besser ausgestattet,
besser ausgebildet und ohnehin besser motiviert ist als die der Russen,
um dann eben eine mögliche Offensive durchzuführen.
Bresnikov meinte Ende April, der ukrainische Verteidigungsminister,
Ukraine sei largely ready to go.
Also aus Sicht der Ukraine seien sie jetzt soweit und das war Ende April der Fall.
Ja zwei Wochen, drei Wochen.
Wobei sie halt viel sagen in der Hinsicht. Sie sagen, dauert noch ein bisschen,
könnte jederzeit losgehen.
Ja alles was wir jetzt machen ist eigentlich auch schon Teil davon,
aber nein wir brauchen noch mehr Zeit, also es ist wirklich sehr sehr sehr auffällig
wie sie die ganze Zeit diese Debatte über diese Offensive am Laufen halten,
ohne sich jemals wirklich auf irgendetwas festzulegen.
Und immer wieder so ein, ja mal gucken, hinzu könnte jeden Moment losgehen.
Und das ist natürlich auch Teil der Strategie, hier die Russen in so einer permanenten
Hab-Acht-Stellung zu halten.
Dass sie nicht so wissen, woran sie eigentlich sind. Dass sie die ganze Zeit
in irgendeiner Form vielleicht glauben, sich auf irgendwas vorbereiten zu müssen,
sich dann aber am Ende für irgendwas komplett Falsches vorbereiten.
Wir kommen in den Mai. Tantz in den Mai.
T.G. Ja, ja. Also dass es für Russland nicht so ganz gut läuft,
merkt man vielleicht auch daran, dass sie dann Anfang Mai mal wieder auch einen
General entlassen haben, diesmal den für Logistik zuständigen.
Also ganz gut scheint das mit der Logistik nicht funktioniert zu haben.
Und dann hat der Artilleriebeschuss auf Kerson zugenommen,
sich ausgeweitet, sodass dort dann drei Tage Ausgangssperre waren und insgesamt
wohl bisher 24 Todesopfer gegeben hat,
da allein in Kassan und auch in den Monaten vorher jeweils bei einigen der Raketenangriffe
sind so zwischen 5 und 15 Todesopfer oft dagewesen,
sodass sagen kann, dass die Russen in
den letzten drei Monaten, um das einfach auch mal zu erwähnen,
weit über 100 Zivilisten und darunter auch sehr viele Kinder einfach getötet
haben mit Angriffen entweder absichtlich auf zivile Infrastruktur oder einfach
mit ihrer schlechten Technik,
die dann halt dann Apartments getroffen hat statt irgendwelcher militärischen Ziele.
Also das ist ja auch so ein wiederkehrendes Ding, was wir in den letzten Monaten
gesehen haben, dass es halt immer wieder so eine Strategie ist,
von Russland auf der einen Seite an der Frontlinie halt teilweise wirklich nur
noch mit Infanterie anzugreifen.
Immer gestützt durch die Artillerie, das ist so ihre Methode,
aber jetzt nicht unbedingt so primär mit großen Panzern und dann parallel dazu
im Hinterland mit ihren Raketen anzugreifen,
die halt teilweise von den Schiffen im Schwarzen Meer starten,
teilweise von Russland aus starten, von verschiedenen Orten aus und dabei halt
ja teilweise den Eindruck machen sie gehen wahllos vor.
Nur man weiß es halt nicht so ganz genau, ob das jetzt wirklich Zufall war oder
pure Absicht irgendwelche Wohnblöcke in Schottenasche zu legen.
Teilweise treffen sie aber halt auch Ziele, die relevant sind.
So Munitionslager, Fabriken, Kraftwerke, so. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so,
dass sie jetzt wirklich nur, vor allem rechts querbeet überall in die Wohnungen
reinhauen, aber es passiert halt sehr viel.
Also wie gesagt, weit über 100 Zivilisten in den letzten drei Monaten,
die dabei getötet wurden. Und ja, das ist nicht in Ordnung.
Aber die Ukraine wehrt sich, teilweise weiß man auch nicht so ganz genau,
wer sich vielleicht wirklich wert.
Großer Hingucker war natürlich ein Drohnenangriff auf den Kreml.
Ja aber dazu wollen wir später noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen,
aber der fand dann auch im Mai statt.
Aber sie schaffen es einfach generell mit der Luftabwehr immer besser mit dem
Raketenangriffen der Russen klar zu kommen. Das ist halt auffällig.
Die RST Systeme sind deployed, die Patriot Systeme laufen.
Man hat so den Eindruck, die Systeme sind in Betrieb, die sind positioniert,
sie werden auch ordentlich benutzt und die Abfangraten insgesamt kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen.
Das weiß man ja eh nicht, sie äußern sich natürlich dazu, aber es kommt immer
wieder nochmal was durch.
Nur die, was sie abfangen, das hat sich geändert.
Auch die Quoten nehmen zu,
weil die Russen jetzt selten mehr als 60 Objekte und die Hälfte davon eher langsam
fliegende Drohnen und gerade mal so 30 Stück von den größeren Kruz Missiles
und Raketen auf einmal losschicken können.
Und die Abfangquoten da liegen mittlerweile je nach Angriff zwischen so 70 bis
95 Prozent ungefähr, werden abgeschossen.
Und im Mai wurde auch das erste Mal vermeldet von der Ukraine,
dass sie mit einem Patriot-System eine von diesen Kinzhal-Hyperschallraketen abgeschossen haben.
Und dann ist, glaube ich, gestern oder vorgestern sind wohl sogar sechs Kinsal-Raketen
bei einem massiven Raketenangriff auf Kiew von der Ukraine abgefangen worden.
Also es war nicht nur ein Glückstreffer, sondern offenbar hat die Ukraine jetzt
auch die Mittel, selbst sogar sechs Kinsals auf einmal abzufangen,
jedenfalls wenn sie auf auf Kiew gerichtet sind.
Und ja das ist schon sehr bemerkenswert.
Das ist bemerkenswert vor allem weil diese Kindersaalraketen,
also Hyperschall ist so ein bisschen verwirrend die Bezeichnung,
weil die Geschwindigkeiten die diese Rakete erreicht, die erreichen auch andere Raketen.
Nur die anderen sind halt solche ballistischen Raketen, die wenn man dann sozusagen
die Trajektorie in dem Moment sich anschaut, dann sehr genau sagen kann,
so alles klar, das kommt da jetzt dahin, das wird dann und dann dort sein.
Dann schickt man sozusagen schon mal was dahin.
Während aber diese Kinsel halt in der Lage sind in dieser hohen Geschwindigkeit
auch noch so ihre Route zu ändern. Und das macht sie natürlich besonders schwierig abzufangen.
Ja, aber dann offensichtlich dann doch nicht so schwierig, als wenn das dann nicht gehen würde.
Ja, es geht offensichtlich mit den richtigen Systemen und der richtigen Bedienung
und das ist ja, sagen wir mal, eine Stärke dieser Patriot Systeme,
dass sie eben sehr flexibel auf solche Angriffe reagieren können.
Und das wurde jetzt das erste Mal gezeigt.
Dann hatten wir auch noch danach einen interessanten Drohnenangriff vor ungefähr
mehr als zehn Tagen auf eine russische Raffinerie in der Nähe von Novorossilisk.
Und das ist interessanterweise 100 Kilometer südöstlich von der Kerchbrücke,
also noch viel weiter von der Ukraine entfernt.
Und ja, da ist dann eine russische Raffinerie getroffen worden und alle haben
sich gefragt, wie konnte das passieren?
Was hat denn die Ukraine da auf einmal, was halt so weit fliegen kann?
Aber dazu kommen wir dann auch noch mal später zu den Vermutungen,
worum es sich Das ist auch nicht der einzige Standort von Treibstoffen,
also in dem Fall war es ja eine Raffinerie, also ein Produktionsort.
Aber es gibt ja auch sehr viele Zwischenlager, unter anderem auch eins direkt
an der Kerschbrücke auf der russischen Seite, was angegriffen worden ist.
Einen ähnlichen Angriff gab es dann auf ein Tanklager in der Nähe von Sevastopol,
was ja der größte Militärstandort auf der Krim ist,
der Russen, also all diese ganzen Ziele konnten erreicht werden und das Interessante
ist, also erstens sie haben diese Drohnen.
Sie können offensichtlich auch ausreichend bedrohliche Sprengladungen mit diesen
Drohnen liefern, aber was noch viel bemerkenswerter ist, sie sind halt in der
Lage die russische Luftverteidigung zu umgehen.
Und das hat wohl auch nicht nur sehr viel mit Technik zu tun,
sondern auch mit Strategien.
Also verschiedene Sachen sind mir so zu Ohren gekommen, dass unter Umständen
halt da auch große Decoys gefahren werden etc.
Genau, da haben wir später auch noch ein bisschen detaillierter von dem schlimmsten
Tag der russischen Luftwaffe seit Beginn des zweiten Weltkriegs erzielen.
Aber das ist so das, was passiert ist, was sich gehäuft hat.
Und das ist halt eben auch eben aus dieser Kategorie, wie man so schön sagt, des Shapings.
Also das sind alles solche vorbereitenden Schläge, die jetzt vielleicht keine
unmittelbar, aber eben mittelbar eine Auswirkung haben. Und das hat sich jetzt
im Mai doch deutlich gesteigert.
Dazu kamen dann auch noch Angriffe auf Melitopol, bei der Strom,
Wasser und Telekommunikation ausgefallen ist, für eine Zeit in der Stadt.
Also das wurde dann auch vermeldet.
Ja, also es wird auf jeden Fall zurückgeschlagen.
Und noch so eine letzte positive Meldung der letzten Tage war dann auch,
dass die Schweiz jetzt auch so ein bisschen weniger neutral geworden ist und
jetzt Waffen- und Munitionslieferungen,
die auch mit Schweizer Technik oder Technologie ausgestattet sind oder enthalten
oder da produziert worden sind, jetzt von anderen Ländern in die Ukraine exportiert werden dürfen.
Das war ja jetzt wirklich ein Ding mit der Schweiz. Also die haben ja ganz schön
lange rumgeeiert und waren irgendwie nicht zu überstimmen.
Worum es ja geht ist, dass halt auf der einen Seite eben Waffensysteme natürlich
in der Schweiz produziert werden, wobei ich ehrlich gesagt nicht genau weiß, welche das sind.
Aber vor allem ist die Schweiz auch ein Munitionslieferant unter anderem für
diese Gepard Luftabwehrsysteme.
Also ich hab gesagt der Bundeswehr, aber sie sind ja nicht nur von der Bundeswehr geliefert worden,
aber halt die deutschen Gepard Systeme,
die in Deutschland ja schon fast ausgemustert wurden und die sich jetzt in Russland
als super super effizient herausgestellt haben für diese neue Bedrohung kleinerer Drohnen,
weil man damit eben auf kurze Distanz sehr effektiv diese Teile aus der Luft nehmen kann.
Ja nur wenn man halt keine Munition hat ist doof und
sehr viel der Munition wurde eben in der Schweiz hergestellt und die Schweiz
hat sich halt auf die Hinterbeine gestellt und hat gesagt so ja ne wir sind
ja total neutral irgendwie wir erlauben es hier jedem Bösewicht der Welt ein
Bankkonto zu eröffnen da können wir jetzt nicht einfach irgendwelche Munition
irgendwo hin liefern lassen.
Ehrlichkon zum Beispiel, so ein Vorort von Zürich, ist so ein weltbekannter
Luftabwehrkanonhersteller schon seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, also schon immer irgendwie.
Da wurde viel von deutschen Rüstungsunternehmen aufgekauft, von der Schweizer
Industrie, aber Rüstungsindustrie.
Aber ja, jetzt dürfen sie dann auch in die Ukraine exportieren.
Aber ja, war ein riesen Ding.
Wollen wir jetzt schon zu Prigozhin kommen?
A. Wir müssen erstmal den 9. Mai die große Parade in Moskau erwähnen.
Es wurde ja am Anfang dieses Jahres schon viel darüber gemutmaßt,
was so die Ziele sein könnten von Russland mit ihrer Winteroffensive und was
halt immer wieder durchgestochen wurde war so diese Überzeugung der russischen Führung,
dass es doch möglich sein sollte bis zu dem Feiertag 9.
Mai, also Gewinn des Zweiten Weltkriegs, sozusagen Niederlage Deutschlands,
dann doch den Donbass erobert zu haben.
Dass es mit dem ganzen Donbass nix wird, das hat sich schon relativ früh abgezeichnet
und es wurde zumindest gemunkelt, dass man ja dann doch zumindest mal Bachmut
eingenommen haben sollte und das verkünden könnte.
Naja, hat nicht so gut funktioniert und trotzdem gab es aber dann eben diese Parade.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendeine Parade, sondern das ist halt irgendwie so das fetteste Teil.
In Russland wurde halt normalerweise einfach auch Herrschern von Infanterie
und Panzer und sonstiger Waffentechnik da auf dem Roten Platz hin und her gegurgt.
Und das war diesmal nicht ganz so. Also diesmal gab es nur einen Panzer.
Und der war von 1936 glaube ich, einer der im zweiten Weltkrieg auch zum Einsatz
kam. Einen haben sie dann ausgemottet
und der stand dann sozusagen für die große russische Übermacht.
Das wurde dann halt als Putins Ein-Panzer-Parade bezeichnet.
Der Punkt ist, es wurden halt auch viele Paraden in anderen Städten abgesagt,
aber nicht die in Moskau.
Und ja, man mutmaßte auch, dass irgendwie der Anschlag auf den Kreml mit der
Parade in Zusammenhang stehen könnte.
Aber grundsätzlich vielleicht noch zu Militärparaden wäre zu sagen,
also das amerikanische Militär oder überhaupt NATO-Militärs,
die wenigsten machen Militärparaden, weil die Soldaten das für Zeitverschwendung halten.
Das hält einfach von wichtigeren Dingen ab.
Das ist das Problem. Nur wenn man halt dann einfach so ein Land ist oder so
jemand wie Putin ist und da unbedingt Paraden veranstalten will und muss,
da muss man sich halt auch gefallen lassen, wenn es dann nicht so läuft,
dass man sich dann der Lächerlichkeit preisgibt.
Es geht ja nicht so sehr um die Parade als solche, sondern es ist ja alles eingebettet
in diese Feierlichkeiten zum 9.
Mai, weil das ja eben sozusagen auch Putins Botschaft ist.
Ja hier die Nazis im Westen, die müssen wieder besiegt werden und wir machen
ja jetzt in der Ukraine ja ganz genau das gleiche und wir sind ja die armen
Russen und wir wollen ja nur das Gute.
Es war diese unsägliche Rede, die er da gehalten hat,
wo er dann versucht hat, quasi jetzt den Überfall auf die Ukraine mit dem großen
patriotischen Krieg in Zusammenhang zu bringen.
Wobei, wenn man das historisch genau betrachtet, hat Russland ja den Zweiten
Weltkrieg mitbegonnen,
man mit in dem Stalin und Hitler sich
Polen geteilt haben und Erst
die Deutschen los und die Russen sind dann
zwei Wochen später in Polen einmarschiert und
ja haben da halt auch unglaubliche Massaker verübt an polnischen Offizieren
unter anderem und ja und haben sich dann aber irgendwann als ja Hitler sich
dann umentschieden hat,
wie das halt so ist bei Diktatoren, auf die kann man sich halt nicht unbedingt verlassen.
Und auch dann nach Russland weiter durchmarschiert ist, hat man sich dann halt
auf die andere Seite geschlagen.
Ja, und dann hinterher so getan, als wäre man armes Opfer gewesen.
Ich meine, ja, Ja, Russland hat ohne Frage mit die größten Opfer zu verzeichnen
gehabt oder überhaupt die größten Opfer zu verzeichnen gehabt im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Aber so völlig unschuldig waren sie daran auch nicht.
Aber was eben auch sichtbar wurde anhand dieser Parade ist,
dass Russland dann doch offensichtlich gerade nicht so aus dem Vollen schöpfen kann,
was marschierende Soldaten angeht und was Panzer angeht, wobei bei anderen Paraden
tatsächlich auch richtige moderne Panzer mitgefahren sind.
Das war jetzt nicht so. Das aber in Moskau halt nicht. Da hat man dann irgendwie
wohl drauf verzichtet und eigentlich vernünftig, aber in dem ganzen Kontext halt blamabel.
Und eben auch so ein gewisses Zeichen dafür, wie es um die russische Armee bestellt ist.
Ja kommen wir mal auf die russische Armee beziehungsweise kommen wir mal darauf,
was eigentlich diese Armee, die dort in der Ukraine kämpft eigentlich so ausmacht
und das dürftet ihr nun auch schon mitbekommen haben.
Es ist nicht nur das russische Militär, was dort,
also nicht nur das offizielle russische Militär, was dort kämpft,
Sondern es ist eine merkwürdige Melange aus unterschiedlichen Milizen privater
und nicht privater Natur.
Also neben der offiziellen russischen Armee hast du halt auf der einen Seite
noch eben diese Untergruppen, also diese sogenannten Rebellen Donetsk und in Luhansk, DNR, LNR.
Deren schicksal so ein bisschen weiß ich nicht also ich habe nicht mehr so viel
darüber wahrgenommen in den letzten monaten welche rolle die spielen und ob
die überhaupt noch eine rolle spielen also ob die überhaupt noch existieren
oder ob die nicht mittlerweile komplett verheizt worden sind.
Was ich mir sehr gut vorstellen kann im Übrigen.
Offiziell ist es ja so, dass jetzt mit dem Anschluss der Gebiete sie jetzt offiziell
auch zur russischen Armee gehören quasi.
Und eigentlich jetzt auch denselben Status und dieselbe Bezahlung verlangen,
aber nicht wirklich bekommen.
Und das wohl auch für erheblichen Unmut sorgt, bei den Truppen aus DNL,
aus Donetsk und Luhansk.
Ja gut, aber was natürlich eine viel größere Rolle spielt, sind natürlich diese
privaten Armeefirmen, die sich Russland in den letzten Jahren so hat ...
Herangezogen hat, sag ich mal. Insbesondere mit dieser stranger Figur von Prigogine.
Wir hatten ihn schon hier mehrfach erwähnt, das ist halt der Chef dieser Wagner Truppen,
der als erstes auf die Idee gekommen ist,
man könnte doch einfach in die Gefängnisse marschieren und Putin hat ihn auch gelassen,
um dort halt Rekruten zu gewinnen, also quasi mehr oder weniger die Leute so
vor die Wahl zu stellen, entweder ihr krepiert hier oder ihr habt eine Restchance
auf dem Schlachtfeld, so wenn ihr sechs Monate für uns kämpft.
Mittlerweile darf er das ja nicht mehr machen, das macht ihn jetzt die Russen selber,
weil sie irgendwie sonst keinen mehr rekrutiert bekommen, aber dieser Prigogine,
der macht halt nicht nur, also er führt jetzt nicht nur so diese Kampftruppen,
die sich selbst ausbilden quasi, trotzdem aber von Russland mit Waffen und Munition etc.
Versorgt werden. Eine sehr merkwürdige Konstellation das alles.
Und die sicherlich besser organisiert sind als die russische Armee,
weil sie die einzigen sind, die eigentlich überhaupt nennenswerte Erfolge noch
vorweisen können, wenn man das denn überhaupt Erfolg nennen will, was sie dort machen.
Und dieser Prigogine als Chef und selber natürlich Multi-Milliardär,
der mischt sich einfach die ganze Zeit auch in diese ganze öffentliche Kommunikation rein.
Und das nicht zu knapp. Nimmt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Videos auf,
beschwert sich, beschimpft die russische Führung, insbesondere den Chef des
Militärs, den Scholgu, aber auch andere kriegen ihr Fett weg und durch die Blume
geht man auch davon aus, dass er sogar direkt Putin kritisiert.
Als Opa in Moskau, als den unfähigen Opa in Moskau, so ohne Namen zu nennen, aber ja.
Und ja, meine, gut, die Sache ist aber die,
dass er zumindest sein Wort gehalten hat,
was jetzt die Freilassung nach sechs Monaten angeht,
das haben zwar nicht viele überlebt, Also geht davon aus,
dass wahrscheinlich bis zu 90 Prozent derer, die das Angebot angenommen haben,
das nicht überlebt haben, aber die 10 Prozent, die es überlebt haben oder die
halt auch teilweise verwundet wurden oder genügend Bestechungsgeld hatten,
die wurden dann auch freigelassen,
was wiederum zu etwas Unmut in der russischen Bevölkerung geführt weil dort
jetzt ja verurteilte Mörder und Schwerverbrecher auf einmal wieder draußen waren.
Und ja, das hat jetzt, wie gesagt,
nicht so begeistert, aber zumindest ist das dann wiederum ein Indikator dafür,
dass er zumindest halbwegs verlässlich zu sein scheint oder nicht nur Unsinn
redet, sondern ja, dass es sondern Dinge auch einfach durchzieht.
Und nur jetzt fragen sich mittlerweile viele Beobachter auch,
wie lange er das jetzt überleben kann, weil,
Er hat nicht nur Putin kritisiert, sondern es sind auch Flugblätter aufgetaucht,
wo er jetzt als Präsidentschaftskandidat verzeichnet ist und angeblich auch
die größte Zustimmung hat und als beliebtester Kandidat für die nächste Wahl
in Russland bezeichnet wird.
Könnte jetzt auch eine Psy-Op gegen ihn sein, also redet er sich dann so raus,
ne hab ich nichts mit zu tun, aber nichtsdestotrotz sind halt solche Flugblätter aufgetaucht.
Und eigentlich hat er auch bereits jetzt zur Rebellion aufgerufen und er hat
nämlich in einem seiner Videos russische Soldaten aufgefordert,
ihre Befehle zu verweigern und sich ihm anzuschließen.
Und das ist etwas, das irgendwie in jedem Land eigentlich normalerweise sofort
dazu führen müsste, dass diese Person wegen Verrat verhaftet wird.
Also entweder ist das mit Putin abgesprochen und alles ein großes Theater oder
dort herrscht einfach absolut komplettes Chaos und Putin hat das gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ja zur Korrektur noch, also er hat nicht von einem unfähigen Opa gesprochen,
sondern er hat generell von einem Opa, tatsächlich von einem fröhlichen Opa
gesprochen in Moskau, aber er würde sich halt fragen, was denn wäre,
wenn sich herausstellt, dass dieser Opa ein Vollidiot ist.
Ja, gut, dann war das etwas verkürzt von mir hier, aber ja, aber ich denke,
der, der Der fröhliche Opa aus Moskau.
Ja, fröhliche Opa in Moskau, von dem sich möglicherweise rausstellen könnte,
dass er unfähig sein könnte.
Also der Typ der lässt einfach Fragezeichen aufsteigen.
Mal kündigt er an, dass alle Wagner Truppen aus Bachmuth abziehen, das war kurz vor dem 9.
Mai, wenn nicht genug Munition kommt. Da kam wohl genug Munition oder sonstige Unterstützung.
Mal sagt er irgendwie, jetzt müssen wir ja alle niedermachen,
aber es gibt auch Gerüchte,
dass er irgendwie im ukrainischen Geheimdienst irgendwie Kontakt hat und dort angeboten haben soll,
für das Überlassen von Bachmuth sozusagen russische Positionen zu verraten oder so etwas.
Also ob das jetzt wieder stimmt, ist natürlich nochmal eine andere Frage.
Ja, könnte auch wieder so eine Psy-Op auch gegen ihn sein,
aber zuzutrauen wäre es ihm auch so Trump-mäßig halt,
Business ist Business und irgendwie,
also würde zum Charakter jedenfalls passen, aber ob das jetzt ja wirklich so war, schwer zu sagen.
Ja, also es wird auf jeden Fall spannend sein zu sehen, was er jetzt sozusagen
überhaupt für eine Rolle spielen wird in Russland und in diesem Krieg.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
So, dann lassen wir mal weiter blicken. Du wolltest ja noch ein bisschen was
zu den Angriffen auf russischem Gebiet sagen.
Ja, vielleicht noch mal was kurz zur Innenperspektive.
Also vor allen Dingen natürlich auf der Krim hat man ja schon gesagt,
dass dort ständig jetzt irgendwelche Dinge explodieren und brennen und tatsächlich
von Leuten, die da leben, die meinten, das sei langsam wirklich nervig.
Und das führt aber zu einer Stimmung, wo jetzt z.B.
Immobilien ganz schwer nur noch verkäuflich sind, weil befürchtet wird einfach,
dass wenn die Ukrainer dann kommen, dass die Kaufverträge, die jetzt geschlossen
werden, einfach nicht mehr anerkannt werden und dass halt eine Restitution erfolgt,
wenn die Ukraine gewinnt. Deswegen, ja, immobilien-schwerverkäuflich.
Mit Ausnahme wiederum von jetzt sehr billigen Immobilien, die eigentlich so
mehr als Schrottimmobilien galten.
Und zwar deswegen, weil jetzt große Teile der russischen Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine,
also Kerson-Kollaborateure oder anderen russischen,
russisch besetzten Gebieten nahe der Front, Die sind ja zu zigtausenden auf
die Krim gekommen und mussten halt irgendwo untergebracht werden.
Und deswegen hat dann unter anderem der russische Staat angefangen auch diese
Schrottimmobilien aufzukaufen oder die Flüchtlinge selbst, sodass deren Preise
dann natürlich gestiegen sind.
Und generell ist die Stimmung in Russland, dass sie sich in diesem Jahr vermehrt
andere Urlaubsziele suchen,
sodass zwar einerseits die Versorgungslage auf der Krim besser wird,
aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich wirtschaftlich das nicht gut aussieht.
Die Krim wird halt nach und nach teurer für Russland.
Mehr subventioniert werden. Und tendenziell, glaube ich, wandern auch Leute ab.
Und die Urlauber haben dann auch ins Feld geführt,
dass sie Angst davor haben, vielleicht nicht von der Krim wieder runterzukommen,
wenn jetzt, keine Ahnung, die Brücke gesprengt wird, dass sie dann da festhängen.
Deswegen bleiben sie da lieber weg und suchen sich andere Urlaubsorte.
Nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, vielleicht noch ein paar Worte jetzt zu der Kreml-Attacke, die wir erwähnt hatten.
Auch wieder eins von diesen Themen, wo man sich fragt, wer war es denn eigentlich, dieses Who-Done-It?
Und was dort auffällt, ist, dass es mehr ein symbolischer Angriff war,
der kaum Schaden angerichtet hat. angerichtet hat, mehr wie ein nahes Feuerwerk eigentlich.
Und so die üblichen Verdächtigen sind natürlich erst mal sind die Ukraine oder
irgendwie eine russische Holzfleck entweder,
Putins Wissen oder ohne das Wissen von Putin oder Gegner von von Putin so ungefähr.
Alle haben irgendwie Motive.
Also die Ukraine natürlich einfach Putin blamieren, den Russen Angst machen
und ihnen den Finger zeigen, obwohl das eher nicht so Zelenskys Stil ist.
Aber ein tatsächlich sachlicher Grund könnte sein,
dass sie damit die Russen dazu bewegen, mehr Flugabwehr abzuziehen,
vielleicht von der Front und nach Moskau zu bringen, weil dann irgendwie mehr
Angst jetzt herrscht. Oh, Moskau.
Und vielleicht auch so ein bisschen ein Intermezzo zum Überbrücken der Wartezeit
bis zur Offensive zu bieten.
Aber ja, wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich nicht so Zelenskys Stil und er braucht
es auch nicht für die Moral zu Hause wirklich so,
wie sich die USA beim Doodle-Tale-Raid nach Pearl Harbor,
als sie dann Japan auch mehr symbolisch bombardiert haben,
das war halt mehr für zu Hause, seht her, wir können auch irgendwie zurückschlagen,
aber das braucht Selensky halt nicht, weil die Moral ist gut.
Für eine russische False Flag, ich meine, wurde halt spekuliert,
ja, vielleicht Rechtfertigung für mehr Crowd-Control im Angesicht auch der Parade,
beziehungsweise, dass vielleicht nicht so viele Leute die armselige Parade aus der Nähe sehen sollten.
Also was meinst du mit russische False Flag im Sinne von der russische Staat Putin?
Genau der russische Staat.
Das kann man glaube ich komplett ausschließen.
Ja Putin eher auch nicht. Also wenn dann jemand in Putins Apparat der meint es besser zu wissen.
Ja und sagen irgendwelche Extremisten im Apparat.
Also das Militär jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht, sondern eher einen Geheimdienst.
Aber da gibt es eben auch historische Zwischenfälle,
so wie zum Beispiel den Mukden-Zwischenfall, wo japanische Militärs einen Krieg
gegen den Willen der politischen Führung inszeniert haben.
Damals mit Russland, da wollte die Politik nicht, aber das Militär wollte halt
so. In dem Fall wird es wohl eher auch nicht das Militär sein,
aber vielleicht, dass jemand dachte.
Im Geheimdienst, wir müssen jetzt, oder ja,
der, ich sag mal, ein Rechtsradikaler im Geheimdienst,
der sagt, wir müssen irgendwie mehr für den Krieg mobilisieren und ja,
und ein anderes Ding vielleicht noch,
dem Westen Angst zu machen und von Waffenlieferungen abzuhalten,
dass das dann eskaliert, so nach dem Motto, seht her, was die Ukraine mit euren
Waffen macht, die greifen jetzt den Kreml an und deswegen gibt es demnächst
Atomkrieg, so diese Nummer quasi.
Aber ja, dass Putin dahinter steckt,
halte ich auch für extrem unwahrscheinlich oder praktisch ausgeschlossen,
weil es war ja ein Angriff auf das Symbol Russlands und Putin sieht sich ja selbst als Russland.
Das heißt, egal ob er jetzt da war oder nicht, das war ein Angriff auf Putin.
Und so und eine riesige Blamage natürlich auch.
Deswegen denke ich mal nicht, dass er dahinter steckt.
Aber wie gesagt, jemand entweder extremistische Geheimdienstler,
jemand aus dem Apparat, der es gut meint, oder natürlich auch Prigogine.
So, ja, würde man jetzt auch nicht ausschließen. Aber Hinweise auf Partisanen
oder Regimegegner gibt es auch nicht wirklich,
wobei ja ein ukrainischer Geschäftsmann Belohnungen dafür ausgesetzt hat,
wer denn als erster irgendwie Moskau angreift mit einer Drohne oder Putin angreift.
Es dann auch gemutmaßt wurde, ob das nicht jemand war, der sich diese Belohnung holen Wutt.
Ja, also es ist nach wie vor ein Rätsel,
so alles ist möglich, so die Ukraine könnte es gewesen sein oder jemand aus
dem Apparat oder jemand völlig anderes, der irgendwie den Krieg anheizen möchte.
Aber wer auch immer das war, niemand hat sich dazu bekannt,
deswegen eben Partisan oder Regimegegner, für die wäre das ja ein Prestigegewinn,
die würden sich dann eher dazu bekennen.
Und es ist auch kein großer Schaden angerichtet worden, was auch gegen Putin
spricht, weil wie wir ja wissen, der keine Skrupel hat ganze Apartment-Blocks
in die Luft zu sprengen, um Stimmung für Krieg zu machen, wie damals in Tschetschenien.
Also es ist auch zu wenig Schaden angerichtet worden, als dass Putin dahinter stecken könnte.
Ja, also es lässt sich auf jeden Fall zusammenfassen, diese ganze Kreml-Attacke,
das war für Russland nicht gut.
Und dass die das auch nicht selber inszeniert haben, das hat man allein schon
daran gemerkt, dass die Propaganda das gar nicht groß aufgegriffen hat.
Also schlechte Nachrichten werden halt einfach generell nur mit,
also entweder gar nicht oder halt nur wie so eine heiße Kartoffel angefasst
und dann geht das schnell in irgendeinem Gedöns von anderen Sachen wieder unter.
Und daraus kann man eigentlich relativ klar schließen, dass es hier zumindest
von russischer Seite, zumindest von offizieller russischer Seite so keine Agenda
gegeben hat. So, das war halt einfach nur peinlich und zeigt halt einfach,
wie verletzt sich die Russen dann doch.
An kritischen Stellen offensichtlich sind.
Und es geht auch vor allem dem Militär, dem Russischen nicht gut,
wie auch unter den Bedingungen mit einem Krieg, der irgendwie keinen Sinn hat
und der so viele Tote fordert.
Ja, ich habe da ein paar wirklich erschütternde Videos in den letzten Tagen
gesehen, die ich nicht unbedingt empfehlen kann, sich die anzuschauen.
Aber eins davon ist von fünf russischen Soldaten,
von denen vier betrunken und verletzt sind und in einem Abwassergraben,
der von oben mit einem Gitter verschlossen ist, sitzen so unten im Prinzip in Schlamm und Scheiße.
Und so einer von denen filmt das, der Einzige, der nüchtern ist und nicht geschlagen wurde.
Und ihn haben sie da reingesteckt, weil er sich dagegen gewehrt hat,
wie mit diesen Leuten, mit diesen Betrunkenen umgegangen wurde.
Und das, also sie wurden halt, einer hat einen gebrochenen Kiefer,
der da, der da drin sitzt und es scheint jetzt so eine Strafe zu sein,
bei Trunkenheit die Leute für drei Tage in so eine Schlammgrube zu stecken mit
einem Gitter oben drauf.
Das haben sie jetzt hervorgekramt und wenn man irgendwie dagegen protestiert,
wird man auch mit reingesteckt.
Dann gab es mehrere erschütternde Videos, wo Verletzte sich lieber umgebracht haben,
also an der Front, weil sie offenbar keine Hoffnung gesehen haben,
dass sie irgendwie gerettet werden.
Und auch teilweise andere russische Soldaten,
die nur zwei Meter entfernt in einem Unterstand oder Loch saßen,
haben sich dann lieber zurückgezogen, statt dem Kameraden zu helfen.
Oder andere Videos, wo viele Soldaten, die versuchen, sich der Ukraine zu ergeben,
von eigener Seite mit Artillerie beschossen werden zum Beispiel.
Und da wundert es halt nicht, was Prigogine auch kritisiert hat in Bachmut,
dass es zu einem ungeordneten Rückzug von Teilen einer Brigade kam,
wobei natürlich das russische Verteidigungsministerium meint,
es sei irgendwie die vierte selbstständige motorisierte Schützenbrigade der LPR gewesen,
während russische Militärblogger meinten, es sei tatsächlich eine eben motorisierte
Schützenbrigade des 14.
Armeekorps der Nordflotte gewesen. Da schiebt man sich jetzt auch dann in der
Öffentlichkeit gegenseitig den Blame dafür zu, wer denn da jetzt geflohen ist eigentlich.
Das sind keine guten Vorzeichen. Es ist jetzt sicher nicht überall so und in
allen Truppen so, aber es sind eben auch keine extremen Einzelfälle.
Das macht keinen Spaß, Russe zu sein in der Ami. In der russischen.
Und mittlerweile auch außerhalb der Armee.
Generell ist für die Russen alles nicht mehr positiv und erschütternd zu sehen,
wie dieses Land durch jahrzehntelange Propaganda so zersetzt ist,
dass es noch nicht mal in der Lage ist irgendwelche Selbstheilungsaktivitäten einzuleiten.
Also ich fand das wirklich erschütternd, was es da zu sehen gibt,
dass einem dann sogar diese russischen Soldaten einfach nur leidtun,
obwohl man weiß, dass, ich meine,
wenn sie selbst sich ihren Kameraden so gegenüber verhalten oder gegenüber Untergebenen,
wie die sie dann gegenüber der ukrainischen Zivilbevölkerung oder Gefangenen
dann teilweise sich ausleben.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz sind es halt auch Menschen und viele sicherlich in einer
Situation, in die sie sich nicht wirklich freiwillig hineinbegeben haben.
Das soll man halt auch festhalten.
Und vor allem scheint auch die Armee die Tendenz zu haben,
sich auch mit viel Friendly Fire selbst zu zerstören und durch sonstige Fehlmaßnahmen,
durch schlechte Kommunikation und das auch in größerem Maße selbst in Russland.
Ja, ich meine, gut, Russland ist ja jetzt sowieso nicht für Sicherheit unbedingt
oder sicheren Umgang mit allen möglichen Dingen im Verkehr oder so.
Dafür sind sie ja nicht bekannt und es brennt auch sehr häufig in Russland.
Nicht nur jetzt die Sabotage, sondern tatsächlich, habe ich mir mal die Statistiken
angeguckt und in Russland brennt es ungefähr zehnmal so häufig wie in westlichen
Ländern, oder wie in EU-Ländern.
Und selbst in den EU-Ländern, die ehemals dem Warschauer Pakt angehört haben,
brennt es nicht so oft wie in Russland. A.
Und vor allem, es brennt vor allem auch länger, weil sie natürlich so viele
Leute mobilisiert haben, auch teilweise von der Feuerwehr, dass einfach auch
einfach das Personal fehlt.
BK'IN DR. Ja, das ist auch noch ein Problem und dann gehen halt auch,
natürlich auch beim Militär laufen Dinge schief, aber dann eben auch sehr spektakulär schief.
Wir hatten auch vor ein paar Monaten dort das Kampfflugzeug,
das ja in ein Apartment geflogen ist.
Und jetzt hatten wir am 20.
April ein spektakuläres Video, wie die Russen ihre eigene Stadt,
nämlich Belgorod bombardiert haben quasi.
Also, was man dort erstmal sehen konnte, ist...
Da so ein verkehrter kamera die so
auf eine große kreuzung guckt und dann fällt
auf einmal dort eine bombe relativ
nah neben der neben der straße und
man sieht so ein bisschen staub und qualm
erstmal und dann fahren halt erst mal
vier autos dort entlang und
15 sekunden nachdem das
ding eingeschlagen ist ich habe das dann mal auf dem video abgestoppt
ist dann diese bombe explodiert und
das muss so wahrscheinlich so eine 500 kilo bombe gewesen sein
und das fünfte auto
was darüber gefahren ist schafft es nicht ganz so das heck kommt dann hoch bis
fast in die senkrechte während er so vorne auf dem boden bleibt und dann wieder
zurück fällt gab wohl verletzte und ein paar Wohnungen wurde stark beschädigt,
dass die Leute in Hotels umsiedeln mussten, aber zu Tode gekommen ist wohl niemand dabei.
Und am nächsten Tag hat man noch eine zweite nicht explodierte Bombe gefunden,
die wohl auch dort abgeworfen wurde vom vom selben Bomber, wo man dann eben
auch noch mal 3000 Leute vorübergehend evakuieren musste, um diese zu räumen.
So, jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, okay, wie kann das sein,
dass jetzt 50 Kilometer, 30 Kilometer von der Grenze dort ein russisches Flugzeug Bomben abwirft?
Hat da jemand den falschen Knopf gedrückt oder waren die nicht richtig angebracht?
Und es gibt da eine, wie ich finde, sehr interessante These,
was vermutlich passiert ist.
Und zwar waren diese Bomben von der Suchol 34 mit auch einem Gleitkit ausgestattet.
Das sind halt dann Flügelzusätze, die halt aus einer normalen Bombe dann eine Gleitbombe machen,
die dann auch ein Ziel ansteuern kann und während sie am Flugzeug hängen,
sind halt die Flügel eingeklappt und wenn sie halt ausgelöst werden,
dann klappen die Flügel aus und dann gleiten die Dinger halt. A.
Segeln sie sozusagen ihrem Ziel entgegen. B.
Genau und die Entfernung jetzt, also die Dinger segeln dann halt bis zu 70 Kilometer weit. A.
Also die ist natürlich nach wie vor angetrieben von einem Raketenantrieb,
aber zusätzlich kommen... B.
Nee, bei den Dingern, die vom Flugzeug abgeworfen werden tatsächlich nicht. Die kriegen hier... A.
Die segeln nur? B.
Die segeln nur, genau.
Und wie lange sollen die segeln?
Die segeln sehr lange, wie gesagt bis zu 75 Kilometer können die halt segeln.
Und was aber wohl passiert ist, also die muss sich natürlich aus entsprechender Höhe dann abwerfen.
Aber im Prinzip kriegst du dann ja so Gleitzahlen, weiß ich nicht,
10 zu 1, 15 zu 1 oder so hin.
Und gut, vielleicht war das Ding auch tatsächlich noch irgendwie mit Antrieb
ausgestattet, aber der eigentliche Punkt.
Es, dass es eben nicht unwahrscheinlich ist, weil dieses Gleitkit ist eben auch
noch recht neu, dass sie halt einfach die Dinger ausgelöst haben und einfach
die Flügel nicht ausgeklappt sind.
Und das halt eben Belgorod quasi der Ort war,
wo man die Dinger tatsächlich, wo sie auszulösen waren, das war einfach der
Auslöseort und niemand hat dabei dran gedacht, was passiert,
wenn die Flügel nicht ausklappen, nämlich dass dann die Dinger unten auf die Stadt fallen.
Und was eben auch dafür spricht, ist, dass die wahrscheinlich gar nicht scharf gemacht wurden,
dass die eine gar nicht explodiert ist und die andere, gut, ob die jetzt mit
15 Sekunden Delay absichtlich war oder einfach nur so beschädigt wurde,
dass sie dann noch 15 Sekunden durchgehalten hat, weiß man nicht.
Wenn dem so war, wäre das halt eine wirklich interessante Sache,
dass entweder das Ding unausgereift ist oder halt die Produktion halt,
das ist eben auch so ein Ding, wenn du natürlich neue Sachen produzierst,
ist die Produktion vielleicht noch unzuverlässig oder es hat einfach irgendjemand
Sicherungsstifte vergessen rauszuziehen,
weil die noch nicht so üblich sind oder irgendwas beim Zusammenbauen oder Anbringen
falsch gemacht hat, weil das ist ein bisschen Ikea-mäßig halt.
Und ja, aber das Ding hat halt einen ziemlichen Wumms.
Also der Krater soll einen 20-Meter-Durchmesser gehabt haben und eben auch eine
super peinliche Sache, ganz egal, was jetzt die Ursache war.
Aber eigentlich sollten die eigenen Bomben nicht irgendwie mitten in einer eigenen
Stadt abgeworfen werden werden und dort runter kommen.
Das kann man glaube ich so einfach feststellen, dass das ziemlich peinlich ist.
Ja also das ist natürlich jetzt ein krasser Fall,
aber es spricht halt auch so ein bisschen für Fälle die man immer wieder sieht,
dass einfach die Russen einfach mit ihrem ganzen Equipment, ihrer Technik Probleme haben,
entweder weil sie nicht ausgereift ist, weil sie jetzt vielleicht in dieser
kurzen Zeit unter hektischen Bedingungen nachproduziert wird oder eben einfach
bestimmte Bauteile, vielleicht Ersatzteile, Material fehlen oder es einfach keine Zeit ist.
Hier sorgfältig mit dem ganzen Kram umzugehen.
Das trägt natürlich nochmal dazu bei, dass alles sehr ineffizient ist,
was sie machen. Und sie haben jetzt ohnehin das Problem, dass sie jetzt in Zukunft
mit sehr viel effizienteren Waffensystemen es zu tun haben werden und dann wird
man sehen, ob sie da überhaupt noch bestehen können.
Ein ähnlicher Fall war ja jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen, also vor drei Tagen, 13.
Mai, gab es dann auch noch ein Vorfall, wo sie es geschafft haben an einem Ort in der Region Bryansk,
das ist halt auch im Norden der Ukraine, Also nicht in der ukraine sondern in
russland sozusagen nahe der grenze der ukrainischen grenze dort waren irgendwie
so ein kombiniertes flugangriffssystem aus zwei.
Schrauber und zwei kampfflugzeugen also einem bomber und einem schutzkampfflugzeug
unterwegs und die sind irgendwie alle vier abgeschossen worden.
Mehr oder weniger, ich weiß nicht in welcher zeitlichen Abfolge,
aber ich glaube innerhalb weniger Minuten hörte ich.
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, aber es hängt auf jeden Fall zusammen und das
ist natürlich schon mal an sich bemerkenswert, also schon der Verlust eines
Hubschraubers wiegt durchaus schwer, insbesondere aber auch natürlich das der Kampfflugzeuge.
Ja ich weiß Russland hat zwar angeblich und an sich eine ganze Menge davon,
das stimmt schon, aber wie viel da wirklich noch von funktionieren etc.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das überhaupt Russland selber noch weiß.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ein schmerzlicher Verlust, aber dann gleich vier auf
einmal ist natürlich krass. Da fragt man sich natürlich was ist es.
Plus, was vielleicht noch schlimmer ist, als jetzt der Materialverlust,
sind halt die vier Crews, die allesamt ums Leben gekommen sind.
Insgesamt sind wohl zwölf Besatzungsmitglieder dieser vier Luftfahrzeuge alle ums Leben gekommen.
Also keiner kam raus.
Da sind die Russen besonders knapp an guten Piloten und haben jetzt wahrscheinlich
allein an diesem einen Tag acht Piloten verloren.
Da ist natürlich die Frage, warum.
Ja. Und erst sagten die Russen, irgendwie technischer Defekt, mussten in Not landen.
Dann tauchten aber Videos auf von irgendwelchen Russen, die einfach online gestellt
haben, die zeigen, dass die Dinger explodiert sind.
Dass die Dinger in der Luft von irgendwas getroffen wurden, also ganz klar Abschüsse zeigt.
Und daraufhin gab es dann Gerüchte über Friendly Fire, weil das war halt auch
jetzt nicht tief in Russland, aber auf russischer Seite eben.
Und dann hieß es ja, die Russen haben ihre Flugzeuge selbst abgeschossen,
weil sie dachten, das wären Ukrainer.
Und das vermeldete so dann auch das ukrainische Verteidigungsministerium,
so sagte, ja, haben wir nichts mehr zu tun. Die Russen haben ihre Flugzeuge selbst abgeschossen.
Dann kamen die Russen aber und sagten dann, nein, wir haben nur die nicht selbst
abgeschossen, das waren die Ukrainer.
Und jetzt bootmasten natürlich auch wieder alle, wer war's?
Aber die Vermutungen gehen eben in der jetzt vor allem westlichen Mail-Blogger-Szene wiederum,
aber auch in der östlichen, dass die Ukraine wohl jetzt über Boden-Luft- oder
Luft-Luft-Raketen mittlerer Reichweite verfügt, die die Russen offenbar nicht orten können.
Da gibt es halt dann auch Berichte von Piloten damals, ich glaube aus dem Korea-Krieg
oder aus verschiedenen Kriegen.
Nee, das war, dieser Bericht war glaube ich aus dem Krieg zwischen,
aus einem der Golf-Kriege, aber jetzt nicht wo die Amerikaner beteiligt waren, sondern Iran, Irak.
Und da kam dann wohl auch das erste Mal diese AMRAMS zum Einsatz.
Das sind so Luft-Luft-Raketen, die so bis zu 100 Kilometer weit fliegen können.
Und wo damals halt einfach nur plötzlich anfingen Flugzeuge,
also die eigenen Flugzeuge zu explodieren.
In dem Fall glaube ich der der Iraker, Weil eben die Iraner noch mit amerikanischer
Technik dann Raketen abgeschossen haben aus einer Entfernung,
wo das Radarsystem der anderen einfach nichts gesehen hat.
Und die dann auch nicht in der Lage war, die irgendwie mit dem Radar zu erfassen.
Es hat einfach nur bumm bumm bumm bumm gemacht.
Beziehungsweise war es dann so, dass diese Raketen dann ihr Radar,
was sie haben, auch erst in den letzten Sekunden einschalten,
um nochmal ein bisschen genauer zu präzisieren, um nochmal genauer zielen zu können.
Und das war dann wohl wahrscheinlich der Moment, wo dann die Radar-Warngeräte
in den Kampfflugzeugen und dem Hubschrauber angingen.
Und dann hatten sie aber nur noch ein paar Sekunden bis zum Einschlag und konnten
wohl nichts machen, wenn dem so war.
Weil was halt auch ein bisschen gegen Friendly Fire spricht,
ist, dass die dann nicht so überrascht worden wären von den anfliegenden Raketen,
sondern deren Systeme sind natürlich darauf ausgerichtet, natürlich auch gerade
Raketen sowjetischer Bauart und Radare und so auf die zu reagieren und dort Alarm zu geben.
Das heißt, es ist wahrscheinlich, dass sie von irgendetwas Unbekannten getroffen
wurden, sie so noch nicht kannten und wo ihre Systeme nicht darauf ausgerichtet sind.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich könnte irgendwas, was auch möglicherweise passiv navigiert
oder über einen Datenlink halt rangeführt wird, der von irgendwo ganz,
anders mit einem ganz anderen Radar mit Positionen
versorgt wird oder vielleicht sogar vom Boden aus Beobachter oder
so und dann erfassen die Raketen irgendwann das Ziel mit passivem Infrarot und
ja und im Endanflug wie gesagt schalten sie ihr Radar ein und da kommen halt
so verschiedene auch westliche Systeme in Frage.
Einmal halt die M120 AMRAAM, wobei offiziell die Ukraine nicht darüber verfügt.
Ebenso die europäische Meteor-Rakete von MBDA,
die kann sowas auch,
aber auch so die IRIS-T SLM hätte halt auch ein ähnliches Angriffsprofil,
aber die müssten dann halt recht nah ran,
so weil die ja nur ungefähr 40 Kilometer Reichweite haben und das jetzt nicht
so wahrscheinlich ist, dass die die IRIS-T SLMs jetzt so nah an die Grenze gebracht haben.
Also was ja immer mal diese These des friendly fire eigentlich schon ausreichend
widerlegt aus meiner Perspektive ist die Tatsache,
dass jetzt innerhalb kürzester Zeit gleich vier ihrer eigenen Flugzeuge bzw.
Hubschrauber abgeschossen werden, also einer ok, wenns richtig scheiße läuft
vielleicht auch mal zwei.
Aber dass gleich vier so unterschiedliche da erwischt werden, ne.
Wie heißt dieser Spruch noch?
Einmal kann immer passieren, zweimal ist irgendwie Koinzidenz,
dreimal ist Feindeinwirkung, ich weiß nicht was bei vier jetzt,
dann wäre bei vier, dann sind sie Ukrainer oder Finnen.
Feindeinwirkung durch Ukrainer oder Finnen könnte man dann vielleicht sagen.
Also so richtig aufgeklärt ist das jetzt nicht.
Es wäre auch möglich, dass es irgendwie ein Integrationstest für die ukrainische Luftabwehr war,
wo sie dann jetzt verschiedene Systeme kombiniert haben, die dann Daten austauschen
und wo die Launcher dann weit weg von den Radarsystemen stehen.
Also ja, aber dass die Ukraine auf einmal so innerhalb von kürzester Zeit vier.
Russische Flugzeuge, Strichhubschrauber, Luftfahrzeuge, genau,
vier militärische Luftfahrzeuge abschießen können. Das dürfte die russische
Luftwaffe jetzt erstmal auf Abstand halten.
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch so ein wiederkehrendes Meme, die Russen auf Abstand halten.
Wenn man sich jetzt nochmal zurück erinnert, wie die Kriegssituation vor ungefähr
einem Jahr, zehn Monaten aussah.
Da hatten wir die Situation, dass der initiale Angriff auf Kiew weitgehend zurückgeschlagen wurde.
Die Russen mussten sich dann zurückziehen und haben sich auf diesen Donbass konzentriert.
Dort sind sie dann entsprechend fortgeschritten und hatten relativ viel Erfolg.
Wir erinnern uns, das waren so die Schlachten um Severodonetsk und Lysitschansk
und dann drohte ja sozusagen der große Vormarsch im Donbass,
aber dann kam alles zum Halten und das hatte ja dann auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun,
dass die Amerikaner den Ukrainern diese Highmars Systeme zur Verfügung gestellt
haben und es auf einmal möglich war über eine Distanz von 80 Kilometern Schläge
vorzunehmen mit extrem hoher Präzision.
Und das führte dann eben dazu, dass sehr viele...
70? Ja sowas in der Größenordnung auf jeden Fall.
Und das führt dann eben dazu, dass eben sehr viele Command Posts, Munitionslager etc.
Logistische Hubs auf einmal unmittelbarer Bedrohung waren, die Russen sich neu
organisieren mussten und alles mehr ins Hinterland verlegen mussten.
Und genau so etwas scheint jetzt eben auch zu drohen.
Einerseits dadurch, dass demnächst diese.
Erweiterte Artilleriemunition, GLSDB Munition, die ja vor längerer Zeit schon
zugesagt wurde, aber jetzt glaube ich auch erst entsprechend produziert worden
ist und demnächst geliefert wird oder jetzt gerade geliefert worden ist.
Das weiß ich nicht ganz genau, aber das müsste jetzt langsam losgehen.
Und es ist ja schon immer auch der Ruf war der Ukrainer doch bitte für die Heimatsysteme
auch die Attacke Mess Munition,
die 150 Kilometer weit fliegen kann, zu erhalten, was ja bis heute nicht zugesagt wurde.
Aber jetzt ist viel Bewegung in dem ganzen Spiel und die Briten sind jetzt auf
jeden Fall dort ganz vorne und haben der Ukraine sogenannte Storm Shadow Raketen,
Long Range Missiles bereitgestellt, die ziemliche Biester sind.
Also das sind halt Raketen, die jetzt in der Form in der sie geliefert wurden
wohl 150 Kilometer überfliegen können und nicht nur 250 Kilometer Reichweite
haben und dabei aber auch noch einen Warhead,
also einen Explosionsmoment von 500 Kilo Sprechstoff haben.
Die fliegen nicht nur weit und präzise und niedrig und sind schwer zu detektieren,
sondern die machen dann auch noch richtig kaputt.
Die sind jetzt auch schon zum Einsatz gekommen, das ist auch belegt durch entsprechende
Funde am Einschlagsort, wo es drauf steht, also auf so einzelnen Bauteilen.
Ja und tatsächlich könnte das natürlich die nächste Wende einleiten und ist
jetzt genauso das richtige Werkzeug,
um wieder einmal die Russen hinter ihren aktuellen Frontlinien oder ihren logistischen
Frontlinien, sag ich mal, wieder in Unordnung zu stoßen.
Also vielleicht noch ein paar Details zu diesem Stormshadow,
weil da gibt es eine ganze Reihe interessanter Kuriositäten.
Da mal los!
Und zwar, also erstmal ist es so ein bisschen,
ja vom Namen her,
Stormshadow ist eigentlich die Vollversion, die 560 Kilometer Reichweite hat
und die Exportversion heißt eigentlich Black Shaheen.
Kennst du das englische Wort Shaheen eigentlich?
B1 Das klingt nicht nach einem englischen Wort.
B2 Doch, das heißt so viel wie Königsfalke oder so. Es ist ein Überbegriff für
irgendwelche Falkentiere und heißt jedenfalls Schwarzer Königsfalke und das
ist die Exportvariante.
Aber offensichtlich mögen sie den Namen nicht und irgendwie Stormshadow klingt
geiler, deswegen nennen sie die jetzt in der Presse überall Stormshadow,
aber es sind eigentlich Black Shaheen und keine Stormshadows, so für Nerds halt.
Und das Ding sind, ja, Cruise Missiles halt, kosten so eine Million das Stück
und haben aber so gewisse Stealth-Eigenschaften.
Radarquerschnitt ungefähr wie ein Vogel, so nicht ganz so gut wie die F-35 jetzt,
aber ja nicht einfach zu orten mit einem Radar und haben halt so ein kleines
Turbojet-Triebwerk dahinter,
was so 580 Kilo Schub liefert und können so mit 1000 Kilometern ungefähr durch
die Gegend fliegen und dann im Endanflug gehen sie halt ziemlich tief.
30 bis bis 40 Meter ist so dann die Endanflughöhe.
Und ja und wiegen aber 1,3 Tonnen. Also quasi wie so ein PKW.
Das heißt man braucht schon etwas größere Flugzeuge als Träger.
Die ganz kleinen gehen nicht und wahrscheinlich kann die Ukraine vermutlich
nur SU-24 dafür nutzen, wo sie die am Anfang des Krieges so noch 10 bis 20 Stück von hatten. A.
Ich habe gehört, dass sie auch die MiG-29 umgebaut haben.
B.
Ja, okay.
Könnte auch sein. Aber jedenfalls geht es nicht auf jedes Flugzeug so ohne weiteres
drauf, weil es sind schon ganz schöne Brocken.
Und dieser Gefechtskopf, den du erwähnt hast,
Er nennt sich Brooch, irgendwie ein Akronym, ich weiß nicht genau wofür das
steht, aber das ist ein zweistufiger Gefechtskopf, der quasi speziell auch dafür
gedacht ist oder in der Lage ist,
tief in Beton einzudringen und der zündet quasi erstmal die kleinere Ladung,
die dann dafür sorgt, dass der Beton aufgesplittert wird und dann kommt halt
erst der große Gefechtskopf und die Dinger können wohl dreieinhalb bis sechs
Meter Stahlbeton durchschlagen oder auch Ziele,
die sich so sechs bis neun Meter unter der Erdoberfläche befinden,
je nachdem ob die gefroren ist oder nicht, so.
Und das ist natürlich vermutlich, sag ich mal, also auch immer gut in der Lage,
so Bunker zu zerstören, in denen Flugzeuge untergebracht werden.
Und ich glaube, dass wenn man da Brückenpfeiler aus Beton mittrifft,
dass da auch schlimme Dinge passieren, ja.
S. Auf könntest du nur anspielen.
B. Ja. Da gibt es doch so eine Brücke irgendwie mit vielen Betonpfeilern.
Ja, also und auch noch interessant vielleicht, wie die Dinger eigentlich zum Ziel kommen.
Das heißt, die haben mal das übliche Trägheitsnavigation und
gps aber gps kann
halt gestört werden und trägheitsnavigation ist
nicht so super genau deswegen machen die
auch noch etwas das nennt sich terra prom terrain profile matching oder geländeprofil
abgleich das heißt die haben so einfach verschiedene höhenmesser und messen dann einfach ja ja,
wie sich das Gelände rechts, links, vor und unter Ihnen aussieht und ermitteln
dadurch, wo Sie sich befinden und wo Sie sich jetzt hinfliegen müssen.
Das ist jetzt nicht, das machen Sie dann im Endanflug, machen Sie das sogenannte
Terracom, nämlich Terrain Contour Matching.
Das ist dann quasi mit einer Kamera oder mit einem Radar,
wo Sie tatsächlich dann nochmal die Geländekonturen abgleichen und nochmal eine
größere Genauigkeit kriegen, aber dies machen die eben auch in rein passiv halt.
Also ja, einziger Nachteil ist.
Das sind halt Cruise Missiles, so das heißt die sind im Vergleich zu ballistischen
Raketen relativ langsam und brauchen dann halt schon mal bis zu 30 Minuten bis zum Ziel,
wenn man jetzt die Vollversion hat oder 15 Minuten dann für die Exportversion.
Und vielleicht auch nochmal, weil da werden wir später auch nochmal drauf treffen,
mit diesen Exportversionen.
Das Interessante ist, es gibt ein sogenanntes Träger-Technologie-Kontrollregime
oder Missile-Technology-Controlregime.
Und da machen 35 Staaten mit und die Ukraine auch seit 1998.
Und die regeln halt, wenn du Raketen- oder Marschflugkörper hast,
die über 300 Kilometer weit fliegen können und mehr als 500 Kilo Nutzlast haben,
gehören zu Kategorie 1 und unterliegen nochmal speziellen Exportkontrollen,
das heißt du brauchst quasi Raketenwaffenschein Klasse 1 als Start,
wenn du halt größere Raketen importieren willst.
Und das Lustige ist auch, dass für die ukrainischen Waffen, die die Ukraine
selber baut, dass sie auch Exportversionen haben.
Aber dazu kommen wir noch später, die auch beschränkte Reichweiten haben,
eben wegen diesem Träger-Technologie-Kontrollregime und was man eigentlich ursprünglich
so damit Atomwaffen nicht so weit fliegen von irgendwelchen Ländern,
die sich dann doch welche zulegen und später auch noch biologische und chemische
Waffen und weil man das eben auch für Terroristen schwieriger machen wollte,
so wirklich weite Raketenschläge durchzuführen.
Gibt es halt quasi diese unter 300 km klasse und unter 500 kilo nutzlast die halt einfacher zu.
Erwerben sind so und ja also ganz schön krasse dinger Jedenfalls diese Storm
Shadow und für sich genommen können wir jetzt sagen ja Ja, eigentlich...
Wären die jetzt abzuschießen. Also wären jetzt kein, würden jetzt die normalerweise die russische.
Luftabwehr nicht vor, ja, unlösbare Probleme stellen. Aber da kommt dann eine
weitere neue Waffe ins Spiel und zwar ist das die sogenannte ADM-160 MALD,
was für Miniatur Air Launched Decoy steht.
Und das sind Cruise Missiles ohne Sprengkopf, also Cruise Missile Attrappen,
die eine Reichweite von 900 Kilometern haben, nur 150 Kilo wiegen,
auch 1000 Kilometer pro Stunde fliegen können und wohl nur um die 30.000 Dollar
kosten. Also spottbillig.
Und das Abgefahrene ist, dass sie ein Signature Augmentation System haben,
das für Radar beliebige Flugzeuge simulieren kann.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt sagen, sie sehe jetzt aus auf dem Radar wie eine F-16
oder wie eine MiG-29 oder wie, keine Ahnung, wie ein anderer Marschflugkörper, wie eine Tomahawk.
Und naja, kennen wir ja alle aus Star Trek, oder? So diese Drohnen,
die dann rumfliegen und dann irgendwie andere Warp-Signaturen und so haben und
sich dann für was anderes ausgeben.
Der Punkt ist nur, dass halt, also erstens die Ukraine hat die auch,
die wurden halt auch gefunden, Teile davon.
Und da kann man natürlich unglaublich viele Dinge mitmachen.
Einmal natürlich die feindliche Luftabwehr verleiten, die Radar abzuwerfen und
Raketen drauf zu verschießen oder andere Flugzeuge auch zu täuschen.
Oder wie im Fall von den Storm Shadows, die eine Million kosten,
einfach nochmal 10 Mauls mitschicken
und die haben dann eine viel größere Radarsignatur als die Storm Shadows.
Das heißt, die russische Flugabwehr
schießt dann auf die Attrappen und die Storm Shadow kommt durch und,
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass auch die russische Flugabwehr an der Kerchbrücke
nicht darauf ausgerichtet ist,
einen Angriff, wo sie mit 20 oder 30 Großmissilertrappen und mit zwei Stormshadows
ankommen, wirklich in der Lage sind, die abzuhalten.
Allein mit dem, von dem wir jetzt wissen, dass die Ukraine das an Technologie
hat, ist sie in der Lage, wann immer sie will, jetzt wahrscheinlich die Kirschbrücke auszuschalten.
Das sollte man mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Sollte man im Hinterkopf behalten, sollte man eigentlich auch im Hinterkopf
behalten, dass derzeit 250 Kilometer Range noch nicht ausreicht.
Also die Ukraine kommt nicht auf 250 Kilometer an die Kirchbrücke ran.
Das wäre erst dann der Fall, wenn sie einen Durchbruch zum Asowschen Meer durchführen. A.
Ja aber die Dinger werden ja sowieso aus der Luft gestartet.
Das heißt die können auch über See von außen kommen oder wo auch immer.
Also die müssen ja nicht von Land gestartet werden.
Aber nicht die Reichweiten mit diesen Flugzeugen. Diese Flugzeuge,
die können nicht sehr weit fliegen.
Das geht nicht. Und sie können auch nicht mal eben so 80 Kilometer in feines
Land fliegen, dann sind sie halt in Nukomaniks pulverisiert,
weil dann werden sie einfach von der Luftabwehr weggekillt.
Also dafür, glaube ich, sind ihnen dann diese Dinger dann doch zu wertvoll.
Also das sehe ich noch nicht, sondern das ist halt etwas, was ich im Verlaufe
der Gegenoffensive unter Umständen einstellen kann.
Andererseits, wenn Stormshadows auch eine Version gibt, die 560 Kilometer macht,
Naja, das wäre ja dann doch vielleicht mal ne Variante.
Ja und eigentlich wie gesagt eigentlich steht da storm shadow drauf und eigentlich
sollen es black shaheen sein vielleicht erzählen uns die engländer auch nicht
einfach nicht die ganze wahrheit was im krieg.
Und sie haben es ja auch erst angekündigt, als die Dinger, glaube ich, schon längst da waren.
Also die Lieferung war längst erfolgt.
Und war vielleicht schon auch länger im Einsatz. Und nur jetzt konnten sie es
vielleicht nicht mehr verschweigen und wollten nicht, dass die Russen das jetzt offenlegen.
Ja ok, aber bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei diesen Ablenkungsdrohnen.
Das ist natürlich eine sehr interessante Technologie,
insbesondere, das war mir jetzt neu, dass die in der Lage sind quasi die Signatur
anderer Luftfahrzeuge zu imitieren.
Das ist natürlich schon wirklich pfiffig und das würde natürlich auch erklären
warum zum Beispiel die Drohnenangriffe auf die Tanklager in Sevastopol so erfolgreich waren.
Also da sind ja sehr viele Drohnen hingeschickt worden, da sind auch sehr viele
Drohnen von der russischen Luftabwehr abgeschossen worden. Aber es sind halt
eben ein paar durchgekommen und die haben dann eben diese großen Tanks zerstört.
Und das war dann sicherlich auch Teil dieses monatelangen Shapings,
weil solche massiven Drohnenangriffe auf die Krim, also mit vielen kleinen Drohnen
anzufliegen, das gab's schon mehrfach.
In dem Zusammenhang frage ich mich was eigentlich aus diesen Bootsdrohnen geworden ist,
da wird ja gerüchtet da hinten die Amerikaner die Ukraine ein bisschen zurückgehalten,
warum auch immer, also diese ganzen politischen Zwänge verstehen wir natürlich an dieser Stelle nicht.
Aber diese Decoys gibt es, die verstärken das, die Stormshadow gibt es, die verstärken das.
Die Ukraine ist einfach dabei ihr Arsenal zu verbessern und vor allem auch teilweise schon zu testen.
Haben wir denn noch irgendeine Waffentechnik, die wir jetzt erwähnen müssen,
dann sollten wir nämlich mal so ein bisschen zu dieser Gegenoffensive selber kommen,
über die jetzt alle… Ja, in dem Kapitel gibt es halt auch noch eine dritte Variante,
nämlich die sogenannte Grom, oder auch Donner heißt das übersetzt, oder Hirn 2.
Das ist nämlich eine...
Ukrainische ballistische Kurzstrecken-Rakete, die so eine maximale Reichweite
zwischen 400 und 500 Kilometer hat.
Die es auch in der RIM-2 Reichweiten- beschränkten Version von 280 Kilometern gibt oder geben sollte,
auch wegen Träger-Technologie-Kontrollregime, auch mit einem 500 Kilogramm Sprengkopf
und ist halt eine ukrainische Eigenproduktion,
die vor vielen Jahren schon begonnen wurde,
wohl von Saudi-Arabien mitfinanziert wird und möglicherweise auf einem der Angriffe
auf dem Militärflugplatz in Sari im August 2022 eingesetzt wurde.
Tatsächlich könnte die Ukraine wohl auch über eine geringe Zahl dieser Systeme verfügen.
Ein bisschen nach dem Motto, wenn der Westen uns keine Raketen größerer Reichweite
liefert, müssen wir sie halt selber bauen.
Tatsächlich hat die Ukraine die Fähigkeiten und die Technologie und so das zu tun.
Möglicherweise haben sie jetzt auch das Geld und haben da auch jetzt eine Produktionslinie
aufgesetzt für eigene Kurzstreckenraketen mit 500 Kilometer Reichweite.
Das ist ja interessant, dass die noch unter Kurzstrecke laufen.
B1 Ja, das wundert mich natürlich auch. Ich meine, wenn sie das haben und die
auch 500 Kilo abliefern können, dann könnten sie natürlich die Krimbrücke auch selber weghauen.
Militärflugplatz Sari. Wo soll der sein?
Saki.
Saki auf der Krim.
Ja, naja, also nichts genaues weiß man nicht.
Auf jeden Fall es tut sich etwas und damit können wir ja vielleicht auch mal überleiten,
so generell auf die Situation aus der Perspektive der Ukraine,
die ja nun nicht müde wird die ganze Zeit ihre große Gegenoffensive irgendwie in den Raum zu stellen.
Vielleicht schauen wir doch erstmal so auf die Verfassung der ukrainischen Armee
und überhaupt der Verfassung des Landes, also nicht richtige Verfassung,
sondern in welchem Zustand sie sich jetzt gerade befindet.
Bei den Russen haben wir ja schon gehört, läuft nicht so gut.
Bei den Ukrainern kann man wohl eher festhalten, die sind nach wie vor hochmotiviert
und sind eigentlich auch durch ihre Erfolge entsprechend positiv gestimmt.
Es gibt so eine Grundhaltung in der Ukraine, die einfach sagt,
das packen wir jetzt einfach, weil wir haben eh keine andere Wahl.
Und das ist natürlich schon mal eine gute Voraussetzung, aber natürlich für
eine Gegenoffensive nicht die einzige wichtige.
Ukraine ist ja gestartet aus einer numerischen Unterlegenheit bei Waffensystemen und Munition.
Wir hatten dafür ein paar mehr Truppen und mussten sich gerade bei Waffensystemen
und Munition an die Russen ranarbeiten. und.
Und wie weit das jetzt gelungen ist, das wird sich jetzt halt zeigen.
Aber generell scheint es der Ukraine jetzt nicht so sehr an Munition zu mangeln.
Und ja, und dann haben sie ja teilweise auch komplett neue Doktrinen und Taktiken entwickelt.
Also gerade im Zusammenhang mit Drohnen, da macht ihnen mittlerweile kaum einer
noch was vor mit Drohnen unterschiedlichster Größen,
die zum Teil auch mittlerweile im Land hergestellt werden.
Auch die großen und mit spezieller Munition mittlerweile, die von den Drohnen abgeworfen wird.
Haben die da noch die so Stabilisierungsfinden und Aufhängevorrichtungen noch
mit 3D-Druckern produziert.
Aber inzwischen gibt es da jetzt auch eine Massenproduktion,
wo die Teile dann schon fertig rausfallen und man die halt relativ sicher an
der Drohne auch hängen kann,
weil es ist halt nicht ganz ungefährlich, so eine Granate, die wenn sie runterfällt,
explodiert an der Drohne anzubringen.
Deswegen, also es ist jetzt nicht so, manchmal eben mit Tape und so,
sondern die sollen halt erstens dranbleiben und zweitens dann aber nur runterfallen,
wenn auch das Signal gegeben wird und nicht, wenn da wie gerade auch eine Funkstörung
ist oder so, sondern deswegen.
Also diese kleinen und mittleren Drohnen müssen auch ein Albtraum gerade für
die russischen Soldaten an der Front sein, die von denen regelmäßig gejagt und
rund um die Uhr terrorisiert werden.
Also die machen denen sozusagen schon einfach das Leben zur Hölle dort.
Ja, und zur ukrainischen Flugabwehr hatten wir auch erwähnt,
die ist auch einen weiten Weg gekommen,
wobei man sagen muss, dass die Ukraine auch mit dem, was sie so an S-300 Systemen
noch hatte und auch an anderen Systemen ziemlich weit gekommen ist,
aber mittlerweile kommen halt alle möglichen Systeme ja online,
also moderne Flugabwehrsysteme, Ich denke, bei den Flugabwehrsystemen.
Ist der Westen am weitesten bereit gewesen, den Technologiekoffer aufzumachen.
Und mittlerweile ist da ja alles da.
Von Nessums Amram mit 30 Kilometer Reichweite, das sind die Dinger,
die auch das Weiße Haus schützen, norwegisch-amerikanische Geschichte mit eigentlich Luft-Luft-Raketen,
die genauso wie bei den anderen Systemen,
wie bei IRIS-T, SLM oder wie bei dem französisch-italienischen System Aster
30 jeweils auf der Basis von Luft-Luft-Raketen ursprünglich entwickelt wurden, die dann wiederum
aus der Sidewinder im Wesentlichen hervorgegangen sind.
Und die denken so verschiedene Reichweiten jetzt ab, die Nessums bis 30 Kilometer,
IRIS-T SLM bis 40 Kilometer.
Dann gibt es eben auch noch sehr interessant das französisch-italienische System Asta
30 SEMTI, was bis 100 Kilometer Reichweite wohl hat,
bisschen teurer ist und dann natürlich den großen Bruder jetzt auch Patriot
mit bis 160 Kilometer Reichweite und dem auch größten Sprengkopf und natürlich
auch dem vermutlich höchsten Preistag.
Und all diese Systeme stehen jetzt der Ukraine zur Verfügung in zunehmenden Stückzahlen.
Irgendwie zwei RST SLMs und ich glaube vier oder acht NASMs und Bei den Aster
3070 ist noch unklar, wie viele das sind.
Und patriot sind jetzt auch zwei Batterien da. Eine aus Deutschland und eine aus den USA.
Und Batterien heißt, das sind immer eine ganze Reihe dann auch von Launchern
und Flugkörpern und Radar.
Und das Interessante ist halt, dass sie sich auch alle wahrscheinlich miteinander
unterhalten können und auch mit anderen Radarsystemen,
Airwags, Flugzeugradar und so weiter auch kommunizieren können oder oder dass
man ihnen auch die Ziele per Datalink, per Satellit teilweise,
überspielen kann. Und ja, das scheint mittlerweile ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Und vor allen Dingen, ja, hat man ja schon gehört, ist auch jetzt mittlerweile die.
Russische Kinschall, diese Hyperschall-Luftbodenrakete im Griff.
Und gestern sind angeblich sechs Stück,
hatten wir ja schon erwähnt, davon an einem Tag abgeschossen worden,
was ja ganz gut returned fürs Geld ist.
Sonst ist ja immer das Problem, mit diesen teuren Westraketen dann auf irgendwelche
Billigdrohnen zu schießen, kann ja auch ein schlechtes Geschäft sein.
Aber so eine Patriot gegen Kinschal ist ungefähr, ja, ist ein gutes Geschäft.
Jetzt hängt natürlich nicht alles nur von Waffensystemen ab.
Das ist alles schön und gut und ist natürlich super, dass die jetzt diese ganzen
Ausrüstungen haben und dass vor allem die Luftabwehr mehr oder weniger auf NATO-Standard
kommt und potenziell vielleicht auch in der Lage ist mehr oder weniger alles abzuwenden, was kommt.
So weit sind wir ja noch nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlechter
geworden, das kann man schon mal festhalten.
Aber um jetzt wirklich schlagkräftig zu sein als Truppe, als Armee insgesamt,
da gehört natürlich noch sehr viel mehr dazu.
Und diese ganze Mobilisierung, die die Ukraine jetzt durchgeführt hat,
wird wohl dazu führen, dass irgendwie so, naja, man weiß es nicht so genau, 50.000, 60.000,
Soldaten jetzt eben noch frisch
mit dazukommen und dann eben für diese Offensive bereitstehen sollen.
Wollen wir denn mal über diese Offensive reden, über die nun so viel geredet
wird. Jetzt haben wir ja eigentlich sehr viel Groundwork gemacht und so ein
bisschen berichtet, was eigentlich da ist, aber eigentlich reden ja die ganze Zeit alle nur davon.
Und ich glaube, dass es auf der einen Seite auch Teil des Plans ist,
der Ukraine, die ganze Zeit darüber zu reden und während bisher so die Offensive
in Kherson so ein bisschen den Rekord,
den militärischen Rekord für wie lange eine militärische Maßnahme von der durchführenden
Armee im Vorfeld schon angekündigt wurde,
den Rekord gehalten hat, wird das also jetzt von dieser Gegenoffensive definitiv
nochmal in den Schatten gestellt, weil sie eigentlich gefühlt seit einem halben
Jahr oder so über nichts anderes reden.
Am Anfang hieß es noch die Frühlingsoffensive, jetzt heißt es irgendwie nicht
mehr die Frühlingsoffensive, weil sie jetzt auch durch mit dem Frühling.
Und die Erwartungen, die Erwartungen, worum es sich denn dabei handelt,
die sind jetzt sagen wir auch vielfältig.
Es wird einen massiven Angriff geben in so einem jetzt geht's los Moment und
300 NATO Panzer rollen auf der vollen Breite der Front alles nieder.
Das wird definitiv nicht passieren. Bis hin zu die Gegenoffensive läuft ja schon
längst, guck mal hier da fällt eine Bombe, hier wird ein bisschen Shaping betrieben,
sozusagen das ist ja schon alles da.
Und ich denke es wird vermutlich eine Mischung aus beiden sein.
Also das was derzeit stattfindet ist natürlich wie alles Teil eines Plans.
Nicht, dass immer alles nach Plan läuft, aber es gibt zumindest einen.
Ein Teil davon ist sicherlich auch die Verteidigungssituation in Bachmuth und
anderen Städten in Donetsk.
Das ist etwas, wofür sich das ukrainische Militär explizit entschieden hat,
wo sie auch eine Alternative gehabt hätten, aber wo sie gesagt haben,
das ist aber das, was unsere Pläne am besten befördert.
Und natürlich wollen wir die Gebiete zurückerobern und wir wollen insbesondere
die Krim zurückerobern.
Ich denke, die Krim ist überhaupt so ein bisschen das goldene Kalb,
also sollte es der ukraine tatsächlich gelingen in irgendeiner form die krim wieder zu.
Einzunehmen dann ist die Niederlage Russlands besiegelt, also mental mindestens,
aber sie können natürlich im Donbass noch ewig weiter so machen,
aber es ist klar, dass sie nicht hinkommen, aber de facto ist dann einfach Putin
eigentlich auch geliefert.
Also er hat schon alles überlebt, aber ich glaube das wäre dann einfach mal
in Russland nicht mehr vermittelbar.
GUTMANN Man weiß es nie, also ja, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich meine,
wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt schon eigentlich ein größeres Problem.
Also es ist im Moment tatsächlich die große Frage,
wie viel braucht es denn noch, also Bevor dann Putin wirklich das Vertrauen
seiner Umgebung und der Bevölkerung verliert.
Noch sieht es nicht so aus, aber oft ist es ja so, dass Dinge erstmal lange
so laufen, dass es nicht so aussieht, als wenn sich irgendwas verändern würde
und dann geht es auf einmal ganz schnell.
Aber im Moment sitzt Putin noch relativ fest im Sattel, würde ich sagen.
Ist mir dann an der Stelle eigentlich auch Wurst so, also soll er meinetwegen
im Sattel sitzen, Hauptsache seine Truppen sitzen nicht mehr in der Ukraine.
Also was jetzt diese Offensive ausmachen soll letzten Endes,
darüber kann man jetzt nur Mut maßen.
Es gibt sicherlich ein paar Früchte, die vielleicht nicht niedrig hängen,
aber die auf jeden Fall sehr wohlschmeckend sind.
Dazu gehört natürlich ein Durchbruch im Süden.
Also vielleicht nochmal für alle, die so die Kriegssituation nicht die ganze
Zeit so wach vor dem Auge haben,
die ganze Frontlinie verläuft so sichelförmig,
im Osten geht's halt so von Norden nach Süden den Donbass,
also Luhansk und Donbass herunter, um dann scharf abzubiegen durch die Oblaste Saporischia,
da wo dieses große Kernkraftwerk ist, bis hin nach Resson und darunter liegt halt die Krim.
Und die Krim wird eigentlich nur versorgt über diese Brücke,
diese Kerchbrücke, die jetzt demnächst dann auch mal wieder repariert worden sein soll.
Meines Wissens ist noch kein Vollzug gemeldet worden, das gestaltet sich wohl
schwierig und mir sagt irgendwie mein Gefühl, wenn das Ding heile ist,
dann dauert es auch nicht mehr lange bis es wieder kaputt ist.
Aber mein Gefühl zählt ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht und sollte es jetzt der
Ukraine in irgendeiner Form gelingen,
durch eine militärische Finte, einen Angriff oder eine Mischung aus dem,
einen Durchbruch auf dieser Südfront durchzuführen,
nicht bei Chassons, weil da ist ja dieser große Dnipro-Fluss dazwischen,
aber in Saporichia, da wo dieses AKW ist, durchzustoßen und insbesondere,
wenn es ihnen gelingen sollte, in irgendeiner Form die Stadt Melitopol zurückzuholen,
die in dieser ganzen Region eigentlich die einzige nennenswerte größere Stadt
ist, aber dementsprechend strategisch dann eben auch wichtig ist,
weil alle Straßen da durchlaufen.
Also sollte so etwas gelingen, dann kann man diese Offensive als Erfolg vermelden,
weil das würde im Prinzip bedeuten, dass man bis zum Asowschen Meer durchstoßen
kann und von dort aus alle Möglichkeiten hat, die Krim in die Zange zu nehmen.
Ja, mein Selenskyj hat, glaube ich, das Ganze wirklich wunderbar beschrieben,
wie denn jetzt aus seiner Sicht die Offensive sein wird.
Und abgesehen davon, dass er sagt, die Gegenoffensive kommt bald,
will take place soon, der dann noch, you will definitely see it and Russia will definitely feel it.
Insofern denke ich mal, da wird was kommen,
was wohl unmissverständlich nach Offensive aussehen wird und die Russen werden
nicht glücklich darüber sein, denke ich.
Das ist das, was mindestens passieren wird.
Wo ja, das Problem ist natürlich, dass die Russen genauso gut wissen, was jetzt von.
Besonderem strategischen Interesse ist und deswegen natürlich auch sich dort
ja wahrscheinlich besonders tief eingraben und dann besonders viele Truppen hinpacken,
während die Ukraine natürlich lieber irgendwo überraschend angreifen möchte,
wo erstmal die Verteidigung nicht so stark ist und dann gerne irgendwie mit
dem Überraschungsmoment arbeiten.
Aber das wird wohl so nicht unbedingt funktionieren, aber wir werden es halt sehen.
Paar Überraschungen würde ich schon noch für möglich halten,
aber tatsächlich wahrscheinlich werden sie,
versuchen genau dort unten Richtung Melitopol und Mariupol, also zwischen Melitopol
und Mariupol oder auch dann Ehordan heißt ist das glaube ich da wo dieses Kernkraftwerk auch ist.
Ja, dass es sich da wahrscheinlich konzentrieren wird und dass die dann irgendwie
dort mit der Brechstange durch müssen.
Ja, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Ich meine bisher hat dieser Krieg zwei Offensiven der Ukraine gesehen.
Die erste Offensive war die Offensive in Kharkiv und die war schnell,
hat Schwachstellen der Russen ausgenutzt und war deswegen erfolgreich,
weil die ukrainische Armee hoch mobil ist,
schnell in der Kommunikation war, schnell eine Lücke gesehen und ausgenutzt
hat und dadurch erfolgreich war.
Dazu kamen noch die Finte, dass sie die ganze Zeit über die Offensive in Kherson
geredet haben und dann sozusagen die Russen sich haben da ins Boxhorn jagen zu lassen.
Die andere Offensive war eben dann die tatsächliche Offensive in Kherson,
die sich geradezu in Zeitlupe abgespielt hat und die mehr so ein Wait and See Approach war.
Es wurde also die ganze Zeit die Brücke, die Antonowskij Brücke bombardiert
und diverse andere Brücken und Übergänge, es wurden mit Heimars Stück für Stück
die ganzen Munitionslager, Versorgungslinien etc.
Logistikzentren wegbombardiert, bis halt dann dem russischen Krieg kam.
Militär irgendwann klar war, sorry aber wir kriegen hier einfach die Truppen,
die wir hier haben, die kriegen wir einfach nicht mehr versorgt und ernährt und was nicht alles,
geschweige denn mit Munition versorgt, wir müssen hier einfach abhauen und so
ist es ja dann am Ende auch passiert,
das heißt eigentlich ist Kherson, ich will nicht sagen kampflos erobert worden,
Aber eben durch eine reine Verdrängungsstrategie, durch ein Geschicktes zerstören
von logistischen Linien und Zentren und wenn man sich halt jetzt die Krim anschaut,
dann ist die einfach militärisch durch eine Offensive in dem Sinne gar nicht
so einfach zu verdrängen.
Ich meine machen wir uns mal klar, auf der einen Seite hast du eine Brücke nach
Russland, da kannst du die ganze kaputt machen, okay gut, das wäre schon mal
ein Anfang, aber du kannst halt da nicht irgendwie angreifen.
Auf der Nordseite gibt es eigentlich auch nur zwei dünne Brücken in einem Marschland,
wo einfach mehr Wasser ist als fester Boden unter den Füßen,
wo du eben auch einfach mit schweren Geräten in Massen überhaupt nicht ohne
weiteres einbrechen kannst und wo die Russen sich halt tief eingegraben haben.
Aber wo sie absolut verwundbar sind, das ist eben genau diese Versorgung der
Krim. Du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, so hier die Touristen und so.
Also da läuft es wirtschaftlich schon nicht so gut. Ich meine es läuft generell
wirtschaftlich nicht so gut, aber da halt nochmal besonders schlecht.
Und wenn die Strategie einfach darin besteht, diese Brücke noch mal zu zerstören...
Weitere wichtige Versorgungszentren, die Flughäfen, die Tanklager, die Bahnlinie etc.
Die einfach anzugehen und ihnen irgendwie so den Hals zuzuschnüren,
dann kann das halt auch eine Offensive sein.
Ich glaube persönlich, wir werden eine Mischung aus allem sehen.
Wir werden sowohl heftige Angriffe und Durchbrüche und schnelle Vorstöße sehen,
da wo die Intelligence der Ukraine dann eben in Echtzeit Schwachstellen feststellt, wie in Rakiv.
Aber es wird auch einem strategischen Ziel folgen, was in Bezug auf die Krim
erstmal ein, ja also ein universelles Shaping macht, bis einfach die Situation
für Russland so nicht mehr haltbar ist.
Also eine vollständige Zerstörung der Brücke wäre schon mal ein guter Anfang,
aber sicherlich nicht das einzige, was da erforderlich ist.
Also es ist definitiv auch, was du jetzt sagst, so die Einschätzung der Mehrzahl der Analysten,
dass sie halt am ehesten sowas wie Kerson erwarten, wo die Russen halt so lange
im Möbel gekocht werden, bis sie von alleine gehen.
Und ja, wir würden natürlich alle lieber Khakiv sehen,
so der große irgendwie Vormarsch und Durchbruch und zurückgelassenes Gerät und
jede Menge gefangene Russen und ja, so.
Aber ja, vielleicht sehen wir ja was komplett Neues, was wir so noch nicht gesehen haben.
Aber ja, was ich glaube,
was man sehen kann, und ich denke, das ist auch jetzt in der Sendung schon mal
ganz gut herausgekommen,
dass in den letzten Wochen sich Dinge geändert haben und dass gerade in der
letzten Woche unglaublich viel passiert ist.
Also dass jetzt offenbar die Ukrainer begonnen haben, ihre neuen Spielzeuge
auszupacken und damit dann auch jetzt zu arbeiten.
Und ich denke, das ist jetzt definitiv der Beginn jetzt der Shaping-Operation
für die Offensive, die an verschiedenen Stellen stattfindet.
Interessanterweise auch sehr viel im Norden gerade, so Richtung Belgorod und so.
Es ist viel Aktivität und ja.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es tatsächlich auch so, dass die Russen nicht gute Truppen
haben, um die gesamte Front abdecken zu können.
Das heißt, jetzt kommt es daneben auch darauf an, tatsächlich die richtigen Stellen zu finden,
wo dann eher die schwächeren Truppen sind und dann auch zu verhindern,
dass die zu viel Truppen hin und her bewegen und sich vielleicht stattdessen
lieber ein bisschen mehr hin und her zu bewegen.
Und dann ganz praktisch wie sowas aussieht ist,
wenn man jetzt so gegen befestigte Verteidigungsstellungen angeht,
da sind Da sind Minen, Minengürtel, da sind Gräben, da sind halt Stellungen,
aus denen man beschossen wird.
Und ja, man muss halt dann die Minen wegkriegen.
Da ist aber das Problem, dass mittlerweile eben auch mit Artillerie neue Minen
gelegt werden. Das heißt, man muss dann halt auch aufpassen.
Die Ukrainer haben das Spiel jetzt lange mit den Russen gespielt.
Die Russen haben halt mühsam den Weg freigeräumt an einem Tag unter großen Opfern.
So sechs, acht Panzer verloren, bis sie irgendwie endlich einen Weg gefunden
hatten durch das Minenfeld.
Nur, dass die Ukrainer dann in der Nacht mit Artillerie da neue Minen hingeschossen
haben und als sie da dann am nächsten Tag wieder reingefahren sind,
sind sie wieder in die neuen Minen gefahren.
Das dreht sich halt jetzt um. Das heißt, jetzt
müssen einerseits die Ukrainer sich halt nur den Weg räumen und frei kämpfen
und dann eben auch frei halten und dann ja Truppen eben auch an anderen Frontabschnitten Truppen binden,
so dass sie nicht zur Hilfe eilen können.
Also das ganze Spiel plus. Natürlich das ist die entscheidende Frage,
wie gut sind die die Ukrainer jetzt darin, dann eben mit kombinierten Waffen
zu kämpfen und komplexe Operationen auch nach Plan durchzuführen.
Dass sie dazu zum Teil in der Lage sind, haben wir ja bei den anderen Offensiven
schon gesehen, aber sich so.
Richtig jetzt durch befestigte Stellungen vorzuarbeiten, das haben sie bisher
auch einfach vermieden, weil sie nicht unnötig viel Material und Leute verlieren wollten.
Aber jetzt wird es wohl nicht ganz ohne gehen, denke ich.
Das wird also jetzt eher kein Durchmarsch werden,
sondern es werden nicht nur die Russen fühlen, sondern wahrscheinlich auch die
Ukrainer zu spüren bekommen.
Und ich meine, wir sehen es ja auch, das ist ja irre, wie viele,
teilweise Teile der Front seit acht, neun Jahren sich nicht bewegt haben,
wo keine Seite in der Lage ist.
Also zum Beispiel, was war das, was war die Stadt?
Und auf der Wohle da,
auf der Wohle da, auf Afdivka, genau,
also speziell Afdivka ist ja wirklich ein Wunder,
weil ich mich gefragt habe, wie es eigentlich dazu kommt und vielleicht ist
es ja auch so eine Balance des Schreckens,
dass sie dort in Afdivka nicht alles platt machen können, weil sie dann Angst
haben, dass die Ukrainer dann vielleicht umgekehrt auch, ja,
was ist das da, Luhansk, Donetsk.
Dann klein schießen werden, sodass sie dann auch einfach ihre Rücksicht auf
gewisse zivile Gebäude dann nicht mehr nehmen.
Und es könnte vielleicht auch sein, dass man sich deswegen zurückhält,
weil man so nah aufeinander hockt dort.
Also wir können jetzt natürlich noch viel spekulieren, was jetzt gemacht werden könnte oder nicht.
Enno sagte es wird sowieso alles anders kommen als wir alle denken.
Genau das denke ich auch und man kann zur Gegenoffensive festhalten also entweder
sie fängt bald an oder sie läuft schon längst.
Das ist gar nicht mal eine Frage,
ob das so ist, sondern es ist eher eine Frage, wie man das gesamte Geschehen interpretiert,
weil letzten Endes ist ja der ganze Krieg im Fluss und eine permanente Reassessment,
aber was halt real ist, ist halt, eine Aufrüstung findet statt,
eine Mobilisierung findet statt.
Die Ukraine arbeitet sehr daran, ihre militärische Lage dadurch zu verbessern,
indem sie einfach ihr Militär verbessern.
Und ich hab so den Eindruck, dass wir jetzt auch was so den internationalen
Support betreffen so ein bisschen so den, die Kulmination des Widerstands gesehen haben.
Also diese ganzen Debatten mit wie weit können wir gehen und wir dürfen Russland
nicht verärgern und dieses ganze Theater was wir jetzt ein Jahr gehört haben, das ist verblasst.
Es ist irgendwie, ich würde nicht sagen es ist komplett durch und es gibt keine Zurückhaltung mehr,
die gibt es sicherlich und die muss es wahrscheinlich auch ein Stück weit geben,
man kann nicht einfach nur blind jetzt dem folgen was die Ukraine alles so für
richtig und wichtig hält.
Nichtsdestotrotz sind wir ja
eigentlich in einer alternativlosen Situation gefangen mit diesem Krieg.
Es ist ja sozusagen vollkommen unmöglich, überhaupt nicht vorstellbar und wäre
wahrscheinlich auch ein großer historischer Fehler,
wenn man jetzt in irgendeiner Form dafür sorgt, dass Russland,
ja ich würde mal nicht sagen Gewinne erzielt, aber einfach allein diese Situation,
die wir jetzt haben beibehält.
Das schadet uns allen auf allen erdenklichen Ebenen, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass es einfach schon eine moralische Verpflichtung sein sollte,
der Ukraine hier auch weiterhin zu helfen.
Aber in der Politik habe ich so den Eindruck, dass mit der Ausnahme von Ungarn vielleicht Ja, äh...
Alle irgendwie langsam einsehen so, ja wir müssen das jetzt vom Tisch kriegen
und wir geben jetzt einfach der Ukraine was sie meint, was sie braucht.
Ja wir müssen nur schauen wie kriegen wir das irgendwie politisch,
innenpolitisch vermittelt und wie kriegen wir das eben auch finanziert.
Und ich hatte es ja schon mal angedeutet, nachdem wir eben jetzt diese Phase
von Deutschland schickt vielleicht 5000 Helme,
wenn sie die finden können, zu wir haben jetzt gerade wieder ein weiteres Unterstützungspaket
in Höhe von 3 Milliarden Euro beschlossen und schicken irgendwie einfach alles
was man irgendwie bei der Bundeswehr
noch abgebaut und bei der deutschen Waffenindustrie bestellt bekommt.
So ist es ja im Prinzip.
16 Geparden und hier nochmal 60 Leopard 1.
Alle Leopard 1, die irgendwo noch auf Halle liegen, so wird alles wieder neu zusammengebaut.
Also es ist ein riesiges, aber was denn auch sonst, weil hätten wir das im letzten
Jahr schon gehabt, diese politische Dynamik, dann wären wir nicht da, wo wir jetzt sind.
Jetzt sind, sondern dann wäre schon sehr viel mehr geschehen und es hätte weniger
Leid erfahren werden müssen bei den Ukrainern.
Aber das ist halt der Lauf der Dinge und das kann man jetzt auch nachträglich nicht ändern.
Aber ich denke, dass das eben jetzt so das ist, was passiert.
Und die nächste Debatte, die wir sehen werden, die also im Prinzip auch schon
geführt wird und die schon ganz anders geführt wird als die Panzer-Debatte,
weißt du noch, die war total krass und der ukrainische Botschafter und alle
haben draufgehauen und es war ein Hauen und ein Stechen und irgendwie ein fassungsloses
Kopfschütteln und auch ich hab mir die ganze Zeit gedacht,
worüber redet ihr eigentlich jetzt noch, ihr habt doch eh keine Wahl.
Und dann kam es nun endlich dazu und jetzt sind wir halt im Prinzip schon an
dem Punkt, wo es darum geht, so okay schicken wir jetzt sozusagen auch noch Flugzeuge oder nicht.
Und es wird so kommen, ja sie werden ihre F-16 Kampfjets, werden sie bekommen,
ich weiß nicht wann, ich weiß nicht wie viele, aber sie werden sie kriegen und
wir werden ohnehin sehen,
dass die Ukraine nach diesem Krieg, so blöd das klingt, relativ schnell auf
NATO Standard festgestellt werden kann.
Also man wird dann einfach schauen, was habt ihr denn für Strukturen und so
weiter. Im Prinzip haben wir genau dasselbe, was ihr auch habt,
sowohl was die Abläufe betrifft als auch die Ausrüstung.
Es wird wahrscheinlich, wenn es gut geht, und dafür spricht halt sehr vieles,
dass es gut geht, wird es sogar noch krasser werden.
Also zum einen...
Ist die Ukraine jetzt schon militärisch das stärkste Land in Europa.
Von ihren Fähigkeiten, aber auch von den Zahlen, wie viele Leute sie unter Waffen
haben, wie viele Panzer sie haben und allem.
Ich glaube da gibt es noch ein, zwei Länder, die du glaube ich übersiehst.
Ich kann dir sagen, wenn man mehr unter Waffen hat. Finnland.
Ja ja, Finnland.
Ja gut, aber das sind, okay, aber materialmäßig und so und es wird ja nur mehr.
Das heißt, am Ende wird die Ukraine als die stärkste und erfahrenste Militärmacht
in Europa aus diesem Krieg hervorgehen.
Und die NATO wird ein Gutes daran tun, die Ukraine auf ihrer Seite zu behalten.
Sie in die NATO aufzunehmen.
Ja, genau. Aber ja, auch wenn es vielleicht etwas länger dauert.
Also ich sehe es im Moment so, ich glaube die Offensive hat,
begonnen.
Und es ist jetzt nicht die Art von Offensive, wo auf Knopfdruck plötzlich jetzt
alle Waffen auf einmal feuern, sondern das ist mehr so ein Ramp-Up.
Weil die müssen ja nicht so wie bei, weiß ich nicht, Desert Storm oder so alle
da von Weipen anrücken, sondern die sind ja mehr oder weniger schon da.
Das heißt, die können halt jetzt auch langsamer hochfahren und gucken,
aber ich glaube, das Hochfahren hat jetzt begonnen.
Also in der letzten Woche, wie gesagt, jetzt die sechs Kindschals,
die abgeschossen wurden und die vier Flugzeuge,
die da an einem Tag abgeschossen wurden,
plus andere Dinge, das für mich jetzt schon so Zeichen, dass sie jetzt ausgepackt
haben und dass es jetzt losgegangen ist und jetzt eigentlich ja immer mehr werden.
Also dass wir täglich eigentlich mehr Nachrichten erwarten können,
dass hier und da was passiert ist.
Und was wir auch gesehen haben, so die Die Situation für die Ukraine ist gut,
auch sowohl weltpolitisch, so hat die Großteil ihrer Welt auf der Seite.
Die Unterstützer senden mittlerweile und die Sachen sind zum Teil schon da und
es kommt halt noch viel viel mehr an so und.
Das gibt zumindest Hoffnung, auch wenn im Hintergrund die politische Situation
in Russland und die russische Moral- und Versorgungssituation nicht so gut und
die Ukraine gut aussieht,
zumindest so aus, als wenn die Ukraine trotz all der Schwierigkeiten eine Chance
hat auf einen spektakulären Erfolg.
Also die Chance ist glaube ich da, es ist nicht ausgeschlossen,
aber sie muss jetzt auch ihr Territorium in diesem Jahr nicht ganz befreien,
sondern was schon, wie du richtig sagtest,
ein ausreichender spektakulärer Erfolg wäre,
wäre einfach bis ans Asowsche mehr zu kommen,
dann gerät halt so viel in Bewegung und dann wäre auch erst mal gut also für dieses Jahr,
dann wäre das halt das Kriegsziel erreicht, aber der Krieg wäre dann noch nicht
zu Ende, sondern wir werden wahrscheinlich auch noch in 2024 und vielleicht auch noch in,
2025 reingehen, bis das ausgekämpft ist,
aber gleichzeitig kann natürlich jeder derzeit irgendein Black-Swan-Ereignis passieren,
Putin kriegt einen Herzinfarkt oder irgendwas anderes, ändert die Situation plötzlich komplett.
Aber das kann man halt nicht planen.
Und ja, ich denke, es sieht gut aus für die Ukraine.
Ich drücke ihr auf jeden Fall die Daumen für die angelaufene Offensive,
die sich jetzt ausweiten wird.
Und ja, in ein, zwei Monaten sind wir schlauer.
Das hoffe ich, dass wir in ein, zwei Monaten schon schlauer sind.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher, dass das sich so schnell abzeichnet,
aber zumindest kann man davon ausgehen, dass sich die Ereignisse ein wenn wir
nicht verdichten werden.
Also Zelensky sagt wir, wir werden es sehen.
Ja aber auch nicht genau wann und so also und ich meine wenn er das sagt dann
kann das ja auch nur ein Teil der Strategie sein.
Weißt du also Krieg ist auch viel Täuschung und Ablenkungsmanöver und das ist
dann wie so ein großer Zaubertrick.
Und Karina hat schon mehrfach gezeigt, dass sie das ganz gut können.
Aber ich habe auch nichts dagegen. Also ich schaue mir das dann auch gerne an,
wenn das dann wirklich zu sehen ist.
Also man merkt es aber auch so bei Berichten jetzt so von der Front teilweise
von Leuten, die da berichten.
Denen juckt es auch alle, die wollen endlich loslegen.
Es gibt den schönen Spruch, so beim Bund gelernt habe, die meiste Zeit des Lebens
wartet der Soldat vergebens.
Aber ich glaube, viele haben jetzt auch einfach das Warten satt und wollen jetzt auch zeigen,
was sie gelernt haben und wollen ja vor allen Dingen auch Leute befreien und
ihr Land befreien und endlich diesen Krieg halt einem Ende näher bringen.
Ja, wie auch auch immer so, dass das merkt man auch. Und deswegen glaube ich,
dass das, was Zelenski in dem Fall gesagt hat, dass das auch so gemeint war,
dass wir es sehen und die Russen es spüren können, werden.
Ja, gut. Ich denke, damit können wir es dann auch erstmal hier abschließen, die Runde.
Viele, viele, viele Details und viele Gedanken. Ich hoffe, das hat euch dann
auch wieder etwas weitergebracht und wir freuen uns auf eure Kommentare und Nachfragen.
Ja und dann schauen wir mal, wann in diesem Theater, so nennt man das ja dann
auch teilweise im Militär, sich dann sozusagen neue Dinge ergeben.
Also es bleibt spannend und wir hoffen, dass sich dann auch endlich bald mal
spürbar das Blatt wendet.
Aber es wird sich wenden. Davon bin ich zumindest sehr überzeugt.
Ja, sieht alles danach aus. Genau.
Also Leute, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Jo, macht's gut, ciao.